Three,
two,
one,
boom.
He got appreciate a person who shows up
with not just food but booze.
You showed up.
He brought whiskey and fish.
That's very impressive.
That's why it's exactly what my mom
taught me.
Your mother taught you to bring food and
booze everywhere.
Exactly.
Well,
you got a good mom,
but.
So your name is you.
You would introduce yourself as
Valentine,
but your mom calls you Valentyn.
It's what I wanted to choose myself to.
English speaking.
People say I'm Valentine.
Right?
But then when I speak to somebody that
speaks French,
I say violence in
volunteer.
Oh,
okay.
Because you're from Montreal.
Yes,
exactly.
Okay,
so I found out about you online and I've
read your story and it's a very
interesting story because you.
You were a lawyer,
right?
Yes.
I used to be low and I did my law degree
in Montreal and then I did my master in
law to before moving to London.
And now you are a spear Fisher.
Yes.
Full time.
It's kind of crazy.
That's a.
that's an interesting transition.
I.
I'm fascinated by spear phishing.
It seems like a lot of fun.
It seems very exciting and dangerous and
risky,
but how did you go from being a lawyer?
And that's a big jump.
I mean,
you gotta you gotta pay for an
education.
You had to.
Well in Canada.
Do you have to pay for that?
How does that work?
Um,
it's,
it's Kinda cheap compared to the US
differently.
It's about something maybe like three,
$4,000 a year.
So competent us is almost free I guess.
Oh,
that's not bad.
Three,
4,000 a year,
but still,
that's three,
4,000 a year for many years that you
decided.
Yeah,
I'll just rather.
My mom definitely didn't get a good
return on investment.
No.
How do they feel about you doing this?
Um,
she still sends me university
applications.
Time to time,
being like,
hey,
when I used to do something different or
something,
and I'm like,
no,
I'm not having a midlife crisis.
I just don't like what it was doing.
So I just picked something else.
Oh,
by the way,
I'm going to have to apologize for my
English.
Seems perfect for Montreal.
So French is my first language.
Well listen,
you're way better than George St Pierre
who was here a couple of weeks ago and
George is more hard to understand and he
was fine.
Yeah.
That I'm not going to speak like this
and make enough wealth to.
Well listen,
I'm impressing anybody.
You can speak more than one language.
I was just in Thailand.
It's just amazing that they speak
English so perfectly,
you know,
and then their languages.
So oddly different than ours.
Um,
you decided when to do this,
like how,
how deep into your,
your law career were you?
It was about,
I actually made a career switch when I
moved to London in 2010,
so I started working in finance.
So I work for hedge funds and I
basically decided on a quitting law.
I didn't like the part of law at where I
was stuck in one place.
So you know,
when you,
when you study law see in Canada than
you.
Even in Canada it's even worse because I
was studying in Quebec,
which is civil law and then I was stuck
in Quebec for rest of my life and I just
got like,
Ooh,
that's not gonna happen.
So meaning that.
Okay.
So like if you pass the bar in
California,
you would also have to pass the bar in
New York if you wanted to work in New
York.
Exactly.
Okay.
That's different than.
Is that the same with like if you were a
doctor,
would that be the case?
Um,
countrywise I would say statewide
couldn't know.
But state wise it is for law.
Yes it is.
So for you,
you would have got stuck in Quebec in
Quebec is a very interesting place
because it kind of doesn't want to be a
part of Canada.
True.
We're very different in Canada,
but my biggest problem with Quebec is
definitely not a culture.
Anything like that is to fight that.
It's an eight month long winter.
It's rough.
My Mom,
I'm not doing what the people are
amazing.
It is.
It's a very European city actually in
Canada it's,
it's people.
People are very about food,
about sitting outside.
Yeah,
to my friends,
David and Fred from Joe beef in
Montreal.
One of the best restaurants in the
world.
Every there.
Yes.
Woo.
That's pretty good.
That's a German place.
So I'm sorry.
So you decided you didn't want to be
stuck?
Yeah,
pretty much.
I kind of got like cluster phobic of
being like,
Ooh,
this is going to be the next 40 years of
my life.
How'd you get into spearfishing?
I'm very weird story.
I was,
I got into spearfishing when I was
living in London,
which still doesn't make much sense.
And then I,
I met,
I met this guy and he was like,
oh,
you have to try spearfishing will be so
good at it.
And he asked me to go do a course in
Egypt the freediving.
So I said,
ah right,
I'm going to go to Egypt.
It's very big for food.
I've eaten.
The sea is like very clear and deep and
what is beautiful and it's calm very
often you can swim from shore and you
have very great depth.
So it's,
it's really nice with that.
But.
So I did my course.
I when they're literally kicking,
screaming,
I didn't want to go.
When I was 14 years old,
I almost drowned and a sat of France
with my parents refused to swim in the
ocean for about 10 years after that I
break if I couldn't see the bottom and
who was not even interested in going
near the water.
And then I was like,
all right,
I'm going to try this thing and I go
there and I'm like,
oh,
okay.
It's not too bad.
No,
it's not that bad.
It's actually really cool.
So he said,
okay,
well now you know how to freedive in
three months.
We're going to this very big spear
fishing trip on ascension island.
Ascension island is literally one of the
biggest,
most elite spearfishing destination in
the world.
You go hunt for big fish.
It's running all over the Atlantic.
It's right between Brazil and Africa.
It's a island divided between the US and
the UK.
Oh Wow.
I've never heard of it before.
To people live on it.
Yes they do.
They have locals that.
What language do they speak English.
Really?
Yeah.
It's,
it's a very,
very odd place,
but it's very pretty
and it's one of the.
There is Jamie nailed it.
Governor up there.
What's the Google maps tells?
How long does it take to get there?
Finishing up in the middle of nowhere.
That's crazy.
In the middle of nowhere,
but wow.
It's between Africa and Brazil.
That's fucking.
I don't get there.
We had to go to the military base and
the and the UK,
which is about an hour and a half away
from London and we have to take care of
burl air force flight there.
I was the only way to get there.
There's no commercial place real as a
stopover on the way from the military
base in the UK to the Falklands.
So how does civilian get a rod on a
military flight?
They allow about five civilians per
flight.
Oh Wow.
So how do you book it?
A travel agent or something?
I,
I didn't do the king myself,
but I think it's like through to the
airline or something.
Wow.
It was a weird experience.
I was imagining like what I was like
being strapped down and then facing the
other side is actually a commercial
flight just because it's bigger guys,
but at the movie Predator now I was
really expecting that and then I get
doors opening the bag and there was like
run out
because I have some friends that have
done some gigs overseas and they have
had to fly in those kind of plans.
That sounds pretty cool I guess until
someone shoots at you.
Yeah,
that would make it a bad day.
That would change things.
So when you were free diving before you
went to this elite spear fishing
destination,
how long could you hold your breath?
When I started?
Yeah,
Siro probably like 15,
20 seconds.
And so you're going there with 15,
20 seconds where the breath.
I was pretty bad.
I just did my deepest dive on my way.
There was something like 15 meters.
Oh Shit.
I'm Canadian.
No,
that's okay.
It's close enough to yard.
We understand what that is.
Five meters 45 feet.
So it was something like that.
It wasn't that great.
And I actually remember my first time I
went spearfishing,
I was on a boat and the word was really
bad.
It was rocky,
you know,
when it sees like black black because
it's raining and I was in the back of
the boat,
I was shaking,
I was holding my little gun and I was
like,
what the fuck am I doing here?
And like one that watching tv right now,
like I don't want to be here,
I don't want to be here,
don't want to be here.
And then my friend was like,
come on,
stop being a fucking pussy,
just Japanese boat,
just jump in the water and come.
I'm like,
ah.
I was like,
okay,
I take a deep breath,
I jump in.
And then the water was so dark and so
horrible and sharp just became super
claim and there was fish everywhere and
I was like,
wow,
this is actually pretty freaking cool.
And you're doing this again,
free diving.
Worried having no,
no tanks.
Well I take my first job so I'm a little
bit clumsy because I have my gun and I'm
like,
oh,
I don't really know how to.
How to
five a debt and then I took a shot down
my first fish and they stoned it and my
friend was like,
oh,
I could live in a first shot.
And it's haunting terms too.
And Yeah.
And then I,
my friend was like,
well you're not done,
you know,
you have to grab the fish,
have to drag it all the way to the boat.
And I was like,
all right,
okay.
Have they finished?
I have always in my face.
And then like I get.
It was quite a big fish.
It was a big,
it was good.
It was a black Jack,
which is not that great to eat black
Jack.
Yeah,
probably something that many people will
eat.
Why wouldn't they eat it?
It's a,
it's edible.
It's not bad.
It's just not one.
It's not a very flaky fish.
I would say.
It's a little tough.
A little tough.
Oh,
so it's just too dense or something?
Yeah,
kind of.
It's their very strong fish,
so.
Whoa,
that's cool.
It converge.
That's what it looks like.
A fish to dale was about like,
like 25 pounds.
Oh Wow.
Your instagram is filled with this
stuff,
which is,
um,
I guess one of the ways that I've found
you have,
it's hard to remember how I find people
online,
but your instagram is filled with you
with all these cool fucking fish and all
these.
I mean,
you look like you're living a life of
adventure.
This is one of the reasons why I wanted
to talk to you about is that a lion fish
are killed.
Yes.
That's a lion fish.
And you eat those.
They taste.
They probably one of the best dating,
tasting fish ever.
Then he realized they're fantastic.
Do you ever get them on them?
Are they commercially available?
Do they or is it
something you can find them at Publix in
Florida.
Oh really?
Which is what I was very surprised
about.
You just have to be really careful when
you harvest them,
of course,
because if you touch a spine,
it's poisonous,
very poisonous,
but it's just painful.
It's not deadly.
Now you can get into a bloodstream
epileptic shock.
Oh,
well good was.
It didn't happen,
but normally you just have like if
somebody was Tommy Tommy's like,
you had a hammer in your head
repeatedly.
Oh,
it's like a throbbing pain for about a
day and a half.
Whoa.
So I got bullied in almost.
It's a paint.
It's not,
it's,
it's.
You really try to avoid it.
All costs.
So what would you compare the meat to
hogfish
so,
or maybe a very tiny Chilean sea bass.
Maybe that type of oily flaky.
Did you know what to do?
We talk about this on the podcast.
Chilean sea bass is not really a basket
to cod
torch.
It sounds also endangered.
So good.
Is it endangered?
How's it on every menu?
If it's endangered assholes.
Um,
so you,
you go to this one destination,
you,
uh,
you shoot this black Jack.
Were you hooked immediately?
Yes.
Real.
It was not about a spearfishing part.
Actually,
I was still traumatized in the water,
still had panics attacks when I was in
the water and um,
but I fell in love the second I arrived
to shore and we barbecued a fish on a
beach and I was like,
okay,
this is this.
Just for me,
the same exact thing that happened to me
when I went deer hunting when we,
me and my friend Brian Cowen and Steve
Rinella and Dan dody were cooking this
deer meat by a fire.
And I was like,
this is the greatest thing ever.
This is the meat was so fresh because it
was like from an animal that was,
you know,
literally killed hours ago.
And then we're eating it by,
by the fire.
I was like,
this is,
I'm going to do this forever.
This is the greatest thing ever,
right?
It is,
it's you,
you feel,
you feel what I was taught.
People list that,
you know,
when you live in a big city,
like when I've never experienced that
before.
I've never felt that I was part of the
ecosystem whatsoever.
And then all of a sudden I've been
putting myself into water when I'm
surrounded by sharks are big fish or
different things and I'm like,
wow,
we're actually not in top of the food
chain at all.
There's a lot of stuff on buffalo's I
can kill us.
And it's,
it's,
it's carrying is humbling.
And I think as a person you have to
experience that.
You have to,
you have to put yourself out of your
conference old to understand that you
need to respect what's around you.
You can tell me 10 years ago,
Oh,
you have g debt fish because it's bad
for drm.
And I'd be like,
yeah,
sure buddy.
Right?
And then you see an implant,
you're like,
Ooh,
that looks good.
Then it's fine and this.
But then when you under water and you
see what's going on and you see that a
spot,
you've been diving for five years old,
southern is empty.
Then it makes you understand that,
you know,
we actually have a very strong impact
and it's,
it's our job to,
to,
to understand and respect it.
We're where we're at,
where did ecosystem,
which is the one that we're the smartest
one.
Sometimes
we're the only ones that are consciously
aware of our actions and the
repercussions.
Yes,
of our actions.
What,
when,
when you're first experiencing this,
your first time eat and this feeling of
connectedness and freedom and just being
a part of the ecosystem,
did you imagine that somehow know that
this could be your life and your job?
Not at all.
I've,
I've never been hiking.
I'm not a big fan of.
I've never used to be a big fan of the
outdoors.
I'm,
I've,
I don't go to the gym,
exercise,
go to the gym,
basically does everything and all of a
sudden I was living in London and the
Nice apartment with two dogs and a nice
car and all of a sudden I wasn't
freaking Africa camping at a Bush,
catching,
catching my own food and sharing with
villages that had nothing to eat.
And I was like,
okay,
well this is,
that happened.
Like how did you go from this one trip?
Um,
I got invited to film a documentary,
food sourcing and I was like,
okay,
I'm going to try it,
and I fell in love with it and the
second I went back to London,
I remember sitting in my desk and be
like,
there's no way I can do that.
There's no way I can keep doing that for
rest of my life.
And everybody thought I was completely
crazy.
I sold everything I,
I and I just left.
I moved away and I,
I have like maybe two suitcases of stuff
for the past three years and
I was reading somewhere where they were
going to do an interview on you and they
decided not to.
They are going to feature you in
something with a decided not to because
of concerns for the depletion of fish in
the ocean.
And I said,
that is one of the dumbest fucking thing
I've ever heard because the impact of
someone like you,
what you're doing for your own personal
consumption,
taking a fish a day or whatever you're
getting for your own personal
consumption is negligible in comparison
to all these people that are probably
writing these articles that are going to
buy Sushi from commercial fishermen.
They're there.
They're buying fish from the store
that's wrapped in Saran wrap.
They're completely out of touch with
mean your intouch.
You're as in touch as you can get.
But to think that somehow or another
you're doing something evil because you
take photos of it and put it on your
instagram.
Who was that one?
You had this amazing photo from a couple
days ago with you.
This is big fish.
It was so fresh and you,
you guys were eating pieces of it.
You had cut a chunk of out of out of its
tail?
Yes.
That was in Thailand?
Yeah,
paquette.
It was.
Yeah.
Actually,
yeah.
We just went with this friend of ours
with his family and we just went off for
the day and we went spearfishing with my
friend.
We caught a fish and and the guy was
super happy.
He cut a right on the spot and all the
kids were just speaking on it and it
was.
They were so excited.
The second year he came,
the second day came that the boat
arrived back to the island.
They just went and grabbed the fish and
they were trying to take pictures.
It was super cute.
What,
what was the argument for not.
What was the piece that they were trying
to put you in where they pulled you out
of it?
What was that about?
That story is,
it's still so getting me pretty angry.
So basically where I was speaking at a
woman empowerment conference in New York
last May and then when I was actually in
Thailand that the woman that is
organizing it calls me and she's like,
oh,
look Valentine,
like I need to talk to you about
something.
And it's,
you know,
it's a little touchy.
I'm like,
what?
She's like,
well,
one of her sponsor said that if you
speak at a conference being on a which
will do participation and the
conference,
what was the sponsor and the Wall Street
Journal,
The Wall Street Journal,
and I'm like,
and she said,
yeah,
do you feel like that's your lifestyle
isn't aligned with ocean preservation
and that.
And she said some.
She didn't say it directly,
but she said,
and you know me,
don't mind that you
have pictures in a bathing suit.
I'm like,
what do you mean patient in my basics
you.
Sorry.
My Burkini was not clean.
Like,
what do you want from me at a beach?
When am I supposed to wear your also
swimming?
I'm swimming.
You're not wearing a bathing suit.
You mean?
It's not like you're in your house
heels.
You know,
being an Insta model,
you're wearing a bathing suit.
There's nothing wrong with that either,
but you're wearing a bathing suit
because you're actually in the water.
Exactly.
I'm not in Mykonos next year.
Fricking pool.
I'm in,
I'm in.
I'm in Africa on a beach when it's like
110 degrees,
what am I supposed to went with Dan
Bilzerian
respect.
So,
so I mean,
what did you say to them?
And that's Wall Street Journal that is
so crazy,
you know,
and I get it from their perspective.
It's a bullshit argument,
but from their perspective it's just
about optics.
It's about how it looks.
That's all it is.
And if they go there and people love to
get outraged about something,
if they go there and then they go to
your instagram and they find pictures of
you with fish,
they're like,
well this girl is cleaning out the
ocean.
All buyers killing home.
Yeah,
I'm very good.
You have to be really good.
I mean,
have you ever seen a commercial fishing
boat?
What they do?
Yes.
Most people have it.
Jamie CV could pull off the horrific
effects of commercial net fishing
because if you find a video,
we can watch a clip of the video.
It's crazy when you see the sheer volume
of fish that they pull out of the ocean
and when you realize there's countless
numbers of these boats and essentially
pretty much unregulated and no one's
watching them and they're doing it all
over the world.
I mean there's areas where you're not
allowed to fish,
but overall it's nothing like the way we
treat wild mammals or wild birds.
The way we treat wild mammals,
especially in North America,
is they're very closely monitored.
Their numbers,
their populations.
We we make sure that unless it's an
invasive species like wild pigs,
like here we go,
this is,
this is awful.
They take this gigantic net,
they circle all these fish and then when
they're pulling them in,
you get to see the sheer volume so you
as they get close,
but that's.
That's.
That's one of the smoother way to
commercial fish.
Francis ready big and it's two
kilometers wide net.
That is actually,
it's.
It's scraping the bottom completely
destroying evidence during the coral
stocks on each side.
This is actually a fairly mild one and
it looks like they're getting these
little tiny fish,
but me,
you could find it folks if you wanted to
go and google it online,
but that is the issue too,
right?
That these,
these nets go all the way to the bottom
and they destroy anything that they
touch.
Like the whole bottom of the ocean just
gets dragged
in.
All the coral gets destroyed.
It's this extremely destructive,
but it's what?
What?
That's how you get Sushi.
There's so much.
The fish industry,
it's not even necessarily how you get to
Sushi.
It's how you get Sushi so damn cheap,
but it's.
It's by DOJ.
If we keep doing that is literally going
to be no fish very,
very,
very soon.
But then how do you explain to us and
Canada,
you know how to spearfish what and you
have to release most of the fish.
You run rail.
There's a lot of stories.
Most of the fishing rod,
unreal reel in Kendall,
stryper is try pass and how many?
How many can you get a day striped bass
like one a day or something?
One day spearfishing.
One a day and and the US site Canada,
you not even touch anything.
You can't use spear phishing Canada
because the Anglers Association in
Canada,
things that were the evil basically,
but you're evil.
Why?
Because you can actually see what you're
catching.
Yeah,
so basically what cheaters,
because we can see the fish and I'm
like,
how can you be in your camping chairs on
your boat?
Drinking Beers all day.
Telling me that I'm the cheater when I'm
working my ass off.
Diving it like 60 feet to catch my fish,
to bring it back.
And I wrecked my life.
I risked my life drowning and was my
left would sharks.
I risked my life with all sorts of
things that can happen and you telling
me drinking you,
but wiser.
You fricking camping chair that I'm the
cheater.
I'm sorry,
but no.
Well,
people always want to think that
everybody else is doing it wrong.
True.
You know,
vegans,
one of the thing,
people that eat meat or doing it wrong,
people did eat meat.
One of the things,
vegans are doing it wrong.
People fish off a boat.
Want to think that people's spearfish,
you're doing it wrong,
you think they're probably doing it
wrong?
No,
I have nothing.
Again,
catching you on food as long as you
know,
respectful what would do where you do
it.
But there was a big scandal in Florida
for the past years with the Brett snap
or by example,
and it was about,
um,
like recreational,
recreational fishing.
You allowed a certain amount of red
snapper and the new season closes and
then when the season closes as an
individual,
my license to fish is gone.
And then he gave it away to the
commercial fishermen
and I'm like,
whoa.
So basically you telling me that I'm not
allowed to catch that fish for a few
months because the population is too
bad,
but then you given my quota to the
commercial boats that are catching
hundreds a day.
They like,
yeah.
No,
it doesn't make any sense.
No it doesn't.
But most people are not going to spear
fish.
Most people are going to fish,
so they don't.
You guys don't have a voice.
Right.
In terms of like representative voice,
some comes to creating these laws and
establishing these,
these rules.
There's not that many of you.
Oh,
we're ready.
And the food chain,
we're the.
We're the plankton is,
you know,
you had a commercial fishing would very
big lobbyists.
Men,
a lot of money and then you have the
anglers uses a little bit.
It's still not super bad because they
still have big boats.
Company and equipment is so like if the
market,
which is good enough.
And anyhow,
spivey,
Shamans were not a lot in the world's
eye.
I couldn't even tell you how many,
but we're not 100 million us for
fricking sure.
It's probably less spear fisherman than
there are bow hunters.
That's highly
possible I would imagine because it
seems more dangerous and difficult than
bowhunting.
Seems like the next level.
It seems like one of the most difficult
things you could do if you want to get
your food,
it's because you're going into an alien
environment and you're holding your
breath.
True.
But actually the human body,
that's the main argument I get from
people.
They tell me,
Oh,
I could never do it,
but every year the human body is
actually made to do this,
so there's a thing called the Mammalian
dive reflex and this is very present and
aquatic mammals such as dolphins or
sales and things like that,
and the human habit in a very way we
create way,
but we still have it and so when you
immerse your face on the water,
your heartbeat is automatically going to
slow down,
especially if the water is colder,
so your body's actually getting prepared
to hold his breath to catch food and
that's.
That's a new DNA.
Is it preparing to catch food or is it
just preparing to survive
to hold your breath underwater?
What reason?
I mean,
I guess I guess that was a very success
of thing to say because it's I'm,
I'm seeing catch food,
but I just don't see why a human being
genetically would have to go.
You're aware of the aquatic ape theory.
Now it's a very controversial theory,
but the theory is that we evolved
somehow or another.
You know,
dolphins,
apparently,
where at one point in time a land animal
is that crew,
is that right?
Were Dolphins Atlanta animal at one
point in time?
I don't know if that's true.
I might have made that up,
but the idea was that humans were the
only ape that grew up in close proximity
to water to the point where we evolved
in the water dolphins may have remains
of legs.
Yeah,
okay.
Fossil remains shows.
Dolphins and whales were four footed
land animals about 50 million years ago
and share the same common ancestors is
hippos.
And Dear,
Whoa,
scientists believed that they later
transitioned to an aquatic lifestyle and
that their hind limbs disappeared.
Okay,
so this is fairly recent.
If you think about evolutionary terms
that the dinosaurs were killed 65
million years ago.
So inside of that 15 million years
later,
they were walking around,
which is fucking nuts.
They were like hippos.
They think so google doc,
whoa.
Look at what they used to look like.
What the fuck,
man?
A Google aquatic ape theory.
Uh,
I don't know enough about this to really
speak on it,
but that has never stopped me in the
past.
But this,
this,
this theory is that the,
one of the reasons why they think humans
have so much fat on us when we're babies
is that we float easier and that if you
take a human baby,
you chuck them in the water.
Okay.
Well,
how about an actual article and how to
picture this cartoon.
Oh,
but it's actually,
it's not,
it's not even just about you hobbies
slowing down.
There's a bunch of things that happened
and you like crazy thing.
Babies know how to hold their breath.
They instantly hold their breath when
you,
that's like Nirvana album cover a
million directions.
Yes,
that's,
that's exactly,
that's what I'm talking about.
Reports
that some humans,
notably children under five may also use
this reflex to survive.
Prolong submersion.
The mammalian dive reflex was developed
in 19 theory was developed in 19
sixties.
That explanation for well publicized
survival of exceptional submersion times
have some near drowning victims.
But,
um,
see if there's anything like are an
actual article that makes sense on the
aquatic ape theory.
There's a new aquatic ape theory from
the Smithsonian.
Oh,
okay.
Hm.
Okay.
The aquatic ape theory now largely
dismissed,
tries to explain the origins of many
humankind,
a unique traits popular as the 19
seventies,
19 eighties by writer Elaine Morgan.
The theory suggests that early hominids
lived in water at least part of the
time,
the aquatic life aquatic lifestyle
supposedly accounts for hairless bodies,
which made us more streamlined for
swimming and diving are upright,
two legged walking,
which made waiting easier and our layers
of subcutaneous fat,
which made us better insulated in water.
Think Whale blubber.
The theory even links and aquatic
existence to the extinction of human
evolution rather of human speech.
The hypothesis was met with much
criticism Blahblahblahblah blom 2009.
Uh,
Richard Rang Ham of Harvard University
and colleagues suggested in American
Journal of physical anthropology that
shallow aquatic habitats allowed
hominids to thrive in Savannah's
enabling our ancestors to move from
tropical forest to open grasslands.
So from two point $5 million to one
point 4 million years ago,
Africa became drier during certain
seasons already dry.
Savannah's became even more arid,
making it difficult for hominids to find
adequate food.
But randoms team suggests that even in
this inhospitable environment,
there were oasises wetlands in lake
shores and these aquatic habitats,
water lilies,
cattails,
blah,
blah.
So that's the theory.
The theory is that we like,
you know,
obviously there's a bunch of different
kinds of primates and some of them are
still in trees today.
Those fucking losers.
We left them behind.
Ha Ha.
Those are the ones that really dumb
people point to.
If people came from monkeys wearing
monkeys,
well Tom,
they were the dumb monkeys fro.
Come on,
get it together.
We're the ones that made cars but that,
um,
some,
some of these apes spent a lot of time
in the water.
And that's why I'm,
if you ever see a baby chimp,
they're hard as rock.
They're like they're jacked baby chimps.
Like they come out like,
like sinewy no body fat.
And you throw them in the water,
they drown.
They don't hold their breath,
they just,
they,
they don't know what to do.
They just gag on water and drown.
Not that I know,
not that I'm throwing chips in the
water,
but that's what they say.
But if you throw a either a baby person
in the water,
they hold their breath.
So this is the quadrant
theory,
but that's what.
That's what scientists are basically
saying about free diving in this is.
This is one of the first lap.
Sorry.
When I first learned about it,
it completely blew my mind.
How long can you hold your breath now?
Five and a half.
Holy Shit.
But like facing down on the water and
not moving and doing a preparation.
Not Swimming,
not swimming,
just facebook.
If you have a dive into the water and
give you what,
how much time do you give yourself?
It depends.
The fish,
Johann to depends on the conditions.
It depends on the lot.
So like if you're fighting the water
occurrence,
it's more difficult.
Yes.
Because basically what you want to do
when you free dive is you want to be as
calm as possible.
You want to be as relaxed as you can,
which is why yoga and meditation are
often very close to free diving because
if your heartbeat is is is high,
then your body's going to need more
oxygen.
That makes sense obviously,
and but then again,
the second year emerge your face in the
water.
You do like your first dive and then you
feel the pressure you body understands
that you're trying to to hold your
breath and you need to do that so the
blood is going to start coming from,
from your fingers.
We extremities,
your toes,
and then you hand you feet,
so all the,
all the vessels I was going to start to
construct so all the blood flow was
going to go towards your vitals organs
so you actually,
you body is getting ready for it,
so they want to make sure that the
oxygen's goes exactly what needs to be.
It makes sure that you need as as less
effort to do anything is possible when
you actually underwater.
Now,
when you first tried holding your
breath,
how long did you have for
your first time?
I did it.
Yeah.
I think my first time trying it,
it was about a minute,
so that was like the best he could do.
No techniques just ready to
no,
no technique like,
like they,
they,
you breed a little bit before.
So even with techniques.
Yeah,
we'll techniques.
It was,
it's when you hold your brand,
you have the ability of two in your body
because you're not excelling any.
And then when you body realizes that is
a buildup,
it gives you an urge to breathe and then
it gives you construct contractions like
diaphragm contractions and this is what
makes somebody panicked.
You know,
like my buddy,
you need to hear when you want to,
you want to hear and then the more you
train then you realized that you learn
how to control it and it's not because
you body tell you to breathe that you
necessarily out of oxygen.
Hm.
So how,
what,
what techniques do you do to relax that
breeding?
So I do mostly,
especially when I'm in the water,
I do a very short inhale,
so about five seconds and then I do a
long inhale,
maybe 10 to 15 seconds.
And then when you,
when you exhale,
you're focusing on like everything
getting relaxed and then you're going to
do that again because you said inhale
twice.
Oh,
sorry,
I didn't mean to know.
So you inhale for five seconds and then
you exhale for 10 to 15 seconds.
Oh,
okay.
So you exhale slowly.
You Excel super slowly.
Use your tongue to control the air
coming out.
And then when you do that you get as
relaxed as possible and then the more
relaxed you are,
that along with your mom will diving
reflex,
which is your heart beating,
slow down.
Naturally you blood shifting from
extremities to your vital organs.
And then you also have about a few years
ago,
maybe only 50 years ago,
they taught that when you reach 30
meters,
you body would be completely crushed
inside.
That was a scientist would think 30
meters.
Yeah,
something like that.
That it was like that the pressure would
be so great there that you body will be
completely crushed.
But then again would that would that
dive reflex.
What it does is that that overflow of
blood is going around you lvl leads in
your lungs,
which prevent ends from crushing you.
Buddies is actually a design machine to
go underwater,
which is completely crazy considering
that.
I've never knew that.
Especially going up in downtown
Montreal.
Yeah.
And then you put somebody in a water and
you're like,
hey,
you actually may for that.
So when people tell me,
Oh,
I could never do that.
It's too hard.
No,
no,
you,
you actually born like that.
So was it,
was it a revelation for you?
I mean,
did you really feel like this is more of
who I am than,
than the life that I was living before?
One hundred percent is I had this,
I was living in London too,
so it was all about all about,
you know,
earning money to buy as many things as
possible to try and impress as many
people as possible.
And then at some point it was like,
wow,
I,
I just,
I cannot do that.
Like you're not spending my entire life
just seeking to buy things and press
people that don't like.
And then when I started spearfishing and
really gave me a different perspective
on life,
it gave me them,
it humbled me in a way that was so,
so intense that it,
it changed my,
it changed my way of thinking
completely,
basically.
So as I was.
How did it humble you?
Like in what way?
Because I realized that
when we were.
Let's see,
when,
when I'm,
when I film a documentary and I'm soften
men,
I film a documentary called Echo and
they grow in,
in Cape Verde Day two years ago.
Back when Negro.
Yep.
I go,
what does that mean?
Black water events in Portuguese.
And then,
uh,
we were there for about five weeks,
five or six weeks.
And then the living conditions were
really bad
and there was no grocery stores around
and we had to catch their own food.
And then it was really a self sufficient
type of chip.
In the first week I remember,
the only thing I could focus on was,
oh God,
this is,
this is terrible that we don't have a
shower.
No hot water or bathroom or disgusting.
I'm starving is nothing around.
And then all you can think is like how
you comfort is gone and after a week
that's the,
the,
the focus change on the good things that
we're seeing around us and why having
nothing all of a sudden then I was like,
oh,
I actually now for the first time in my
life can take the time to realize what's
good around me and then how we were
having fires with the neighbors and then
how we were offering and fish.
And we were thinking,
oh,
you know,
if I give this guy to fish is going to
eat one today and one tomorrow.
But no,
the inviting neighbors to share when
they make sure that it was like a whole,
like community sends to all of it.
And I was like,
wow,
I've been living in London for six
years.
I don't even know the name of the
neighbor.
And it's,
it's,
it's bad.
It's just not a way of living that I
want.
It's not focusing in a right things.
And it's,
it was that,
that's in that way,
you know,
it's realized how much of how much of an
asshole we actually became.
And I just didn't want to do that.
Well,
it's a very recent way that people have
been living this,
this way of living in apartment
buildings and the way of living in
houses where we don't know our neighbors
in terms of human history.
It's very recent and I don't think we're
designed for it.
I don't think so either.
It's the,
the human.
I do believe that a human being to be
happy,
you need to have the sense of community,
which is why,
you know,
when you go into subway and you see like
somebody seeing everybody's laughing and
you see those videos,
youtube and it makes you all warm and
happy inside is because that's what we
were meant to be,
you know,
and it's women to live with other
people.
We meant to socialize.
We meant to have this,
this,
this strong feeling of,
of,
of um,
I don't know how to say that in English.
I'm give,
be part of something to be part of a
group and people like that.
And um,
I do think it's a necessity for human
being to be actually happy.
I think so too.
And I think that's probably one of the
reasons why so many people are so
grossly unhappy and so depressed and so
disconnected and they feel alienated
even though they live in these giant
cities.
People feel extremely lonely even though
there's a lot of people around me.
I'm one of the weirder things about New
York City,
you know,
our friends live in New York City and
one of the things they say they love is
how many people were there?
It's,
there's all this energy,
all this energy.
I'm like,
yeah,
we're not even talking to those people.
That's what's weird.
It's like you're alienated in this
little 1200 foot little cubicle that you
live in.
You know,
this little,
I guess 1200 foot on that small.
But you know,
some of them like Ari's places,
like I have to ask them,
I think it's tiny.
It's probably like half.
That's like 600 feet.
I was probably like $5 million promise.
Stupid expensive.
Right?
But the idea is that you don't know
anybody around you,
but you're stacked around all these
people and then you go out,
you're walking around these people,
but you're not really talking to them
and you have a few people that you're
friends with maybe that you work with
and you interact with them,
but then you're constantly surrounded by
all these other people that you don't
even know.
It's a very weird,
weird way to live.
Whereas the way you were living,
the way you were describing this with
these people and they're all sharing
fish and they're,
you know,
you're.
Everyone's taken care of everybody and
giving some to their neighbors and
sharing.
And that's how people have been living
forever.
I think there's certain human reward
systems that are built into who we are
as a being,
as a species that just aren't being met.
And that's why I'm so fascinated by your
choice to go from being a lawyer to
living this.
You know,
very a very interesting life of spear
fishing.
But it's also,
it's,
it's not always easy in the sense that
I,
I still haven't found a place.
What I want to live,
because it's the society isn't designed
for this.
My lifestyle is very hard to adapt with
modern society.
I struggle with a lot of things.
I don't know.
I don't know where to live.
I don't know because this has a
community,
you can have it in small villages.
So that's kind of why I've been living
in,
um,
well that anymore.
But letting them to Bahamas for a year
and I got to experience.
That's when everybody knows each other.
Everybody talked to each other to stay
there.
Um,
because for now I guess what I,
I couldn't,
I woke up and my ex boyfriend,
I couldn't live there anymore,
so I was his house.
I was like,
all right,
I'm out.
So that is,
I,
I just,
I don't know,
it's,
I still need,
you know,
to survive,
I suddenly,
yeah,
I catch a lot of my own food and my
freezer's literally full to.
But I,
I,
you still need money to live.
Right.
And how do you make money?
Um,
I get a few things.
I'm working right now on,
on a cookbook and a TV show with a
Canadian company.
Do you make any money off your instagram
page?
Oh yeah.
Sometimes some people do.
Right?
Sometimes.
How do you do that?
How do you make money off your
instagram?
Like sponsors and different things like
that.
I just don't like being like,
hey,
drink my detox tea,
skinny tea.
I just,
I just don't like doing that.
And the problem also is like,
was it two years ago?
I was a super big contract with a crew
sheet company.
They needed a girl to like,
they need to free freediving goal and
we're not that many of us.
So when they hired me at about a week
later,
she calls me back.
She's like,
Oh,
I'm sorry we can't hire you anymore.
I'm like,
what?
Why?
And she says,
because we're partnering with WWF and
our marketing,
our marketing department said you raised
a red flag because you spit fish for a
living
ww f the wrestling wwe.
Wow.
That like dependent on like the one,
the one with dependent,
the one that made them change the name,
but wwe the worldwide.
Yeah,
that's what it used to be.
But what do you.
Is that what you're saying?
The wrestling pro wrestling?
No,
no,
no.
The,
the ECO friendly.
Oh,
dependent world.
Wildlife Federation.
Oh,
they made them change their name.
That's why they changed her name.
Oh,
I thought they changed the name because
of a lawsuit because they had to show
that they were entertainment.
Let's see.
Huh.
So wwf owned it?
I believe so.
I didn't know that.
I really thought that it was just
because of regulations.
WWF was so,
so basically,
yeah.
They said like,
oh,
because we really want to keep or eco
friendly.
Meanwhile they're fucking boats filled
with rows,
beef,
chicken and all sorts of other shifts.
Well,
one day crossed they're allowed.
I think it's about when you two miles
away from the coast,
you're allowed to dump your garbage and
the ocean.
Everything as a cruise ship we allowed
to open a trap and just throw everything
in the freaking ocean.
Is that true?
It's true.
The law.
It's the law and,
and we do that.
Of course they do that.
Oh my God,
that's one of them.
That's one of the problem.
How many the five people cruise ship,
how many destroyed thing to use in
glasses because they're too lazy to
Washington.
That's one of the problem.
And then the Bahamas,
you know what you know how much dredging
you need to make for,
for cruise ship a boat.
Boats actually pass and dock somewhere.
He to rip up the entire bottom of the
ocean.
So it's deep enough.
It's a very,
very detrimental,
um,
organization for the,
for,
for the ocean.
And then they tell me,
start to become where would you,
because you catch you on food and
underwater it was bad for the ocean.
I'm like,
what?
I cashed my own food.
I don't buy this disgusting farm salmon
from whole food because it's gross.
And Are you telling me that I'm bad?
Like what?
Most
people don't know that farm salmon,
they die the fish to make it look
orange.
Like if you buy farm salmon and they're
not dying,
it would be a white meat because they're
not eating what they eat.
Naturally.
It's bugs.
Certain bugs give them or shrimp.
What is it?
No,
it's um,
Pelicans,
not pelicans.
One of those little fucking weird reps.
the ones that people have in their
lawns.
Salmon is not pale orange.
It's dark.
Omega Flamingos
are pink because of this.
This shrimp they eat.
Right.
Thanks.
So yeah,
it literally makes them pink salmon or
dark when they're wild because of their
diet,
their natural diet,
which includes a lot of bugs I guess.
Yeah.
They basically feed them and whatever
they have.
Like salmon is not supposed to be Pale
orange.
Dark orange,
right?
Yeah.
I've caught wild salmon before.
It's awesome.
It is really good.
But sadly with all them,
the water dam that he made to make
electricity and that almost of like
daddy killed all of them.
Well the killed quite a few.
There was a,
there's an interesting place in Seattle
where you can go and watch the salmon
swim up river.
There's like a bridge and you go
underneath the bridge and they have this
setup where there's a thick glass walls.
We can actually look into the ocean and
wash the salmon,
go up the salmon ladder.
It's really fascinating,
so it's crazy to watch them,
but one of the guys who was there who
was a guide who was explaining how when
they were doing construction and doing
various things and they're building
Seattle,
they had shut down one of the rivers and
the salmon would just get to the mouth
of the river where they thought they
were supposed to go and fucking die and
it was crazy,
like millions of them died while they
were trying to figure out a way to carve
this path again.
Yeah,
it's very.
We added dye to it.
Like Rut.
Yeah.
I went to.
Oh,
and diving in the when the Salmon River
and and BC and I was underwater with my
gut.
I could see that had like big stains of
like Rut on their body.
So they live like a full live in the
ocean and they came to breed one last
time,
which I guess is a good last tours when
you think about it and then it just
brought to debt.
Yeah.
It's very strange.
And if you catch them too far along the
process,
their body's already deteriorated.
Like um,
you know,
I know guys who have caught them and
then you can save in survival situations
like people eat them because you have
to.
But if you caught them like towards the
end of their cycle,
their bodies like mush again,
literally shoved your fingers.
You're through
it.
Yeah.
Well it's.
But you see that's what,
that's what people eat.
But again,
you know,
the Wall Street Journal than the
instagram page when they promoting a
recipe for shrimp are probably coming
from Thailand or sound that is farm and
very bad for the environment.
But then they think that,
I don't know.
I,
there's something ridiculously taboo
about catching food.
It's ridiculous.
And people imagine,
you know,
how I know have been hunting has a bad
reputation for four because of the blog
and and things like that.
But I went fishing,
we deal on top of it,
what a bunch of lobbyists that are
finding us for deficient of same time
because they want to sell those because
they wanted to fish and all we are for
them as something in the way and we
don't buy their fish at all because
there's so few of you they can,
they can,
they can see anything that they want
about us and we don't have the power to,
to say something back.
Right?
If they shut down sports,
fear,
spear fishing,
there were really wouldn't be much
outcry.
How many spear Fisher people are there.
I will lose my shit but I don't do much
while you make a post on instagram and a
couple of people would like it.
I got 5,000 likes.
How many spear Fisher people are in the
country?
Let's,
let's Google just America just started
states.
How many spear fit?
How would you know?
Because do you have to.
You don't have to have the license for,
for the ocean,
right?
It depends on the state.
Some states slower day.
You Do,
you do have to have a license in
Florida.
You.
Oh,
interesting.
Well it's like,
you know,
$25 license and I googled that and
there's a city called spearfish.
South Dakota gave me the populations
don't know how to find it.
Um,
how many active just right spear
fishermen.
No disrespect to the spear.
Fisher ladies.
We count that much in the.
How many spear fishermen are there in
the United States?
Going back to that state or the city?
It's growing really fast.
Actually.
It is going fast.
There is like a trend now for people to
catch me on food and people are starting
slowly because there's so many of big
people,
specialist celebrities
that spearfishing voicing themselves
when it comes to food of saying and now
people are starting to realize that
hunting or spearfishing is actually not
as bad.
It's way better,
but it's just very difficult.
You know,
sports illustrated,
there's estimated between $1,000,002
million.
So in the country.
Yeah,
I highly doubt it.
That's a lot of people.
That's like almost close to one percent,
right?
There's 3 million people.
There's 2 million,
300 million people.
Rather if there's 2 million spear Fisher
people close.
Yeah,
but that's.
That doesn't make sense.
That's ridiculous.
That's.
I mean,
even if it was one half of a percent,
that's crazy.
So you telling me if you get a room of
200 people,
one of them's going to be a spear
fishermen.
Get the fuck.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
This article I just saw the very,
very top is from 1954.
Only 80 people alive.
That makes it even worse.
That's hilarious.
You talk about pulling the people.
You're a pro good articles from 2016.
You should know if you want to take up
spearfishing.
Wow.
By the know it all.
That's crazy.
Nineteen 54.
So I'll try it again.
Okay.
Just give it a shot.
Whatever.
I mean it's a great sport is the best
way.
It's the best way to eat fish and
seafood.
Oh,
I can only imagine.
I love,
I love fishing.
It's really fun.
It can be a little stressful sometimes.
I get that,
but it's.
Imagine if you floating,
you're floating in a salt water tank and
then you looking around and you try to
meditate as much as you can and then
you're waiting you in hunting mode.
You focusing on your pray to try to get
it and then you have like five grizzly
bears that are circling and you try to
eat your ass.
Does that happen?
I try to eat a fish that you.
Do you ever do get approached by sharks
in the Bahamas?
Yeah,
Bahamas.
They're pretty much always there.
There's a guy who just got bit in Texas.
He got bit by a bull shark and now he
has flesh eating bacteria that's
destroying his leg.
Apparently this flesh eating bacteria in
the water,
we don't need to google that.
It's pretty bad.
Pretty disgusting.
I can pretty bad encounters with sharks.
What happened?
My worst one was in Tampa,
actually something super easy.
It was in 15 feet of water and that's
actually the dangerous spearphishing is
when you start getting cocky and you say
like,
ah,
what is shallow?
It's fine.
We don't have to watch each other.
Everybody's doing their own thing,
which is really bad.
Definitely never do this.
I got my lesson breakdown and I was.
I showed a little fish,
do I clip it to the back of my gun and
then this tiger shark come in and I'm
like,
Ooh,
tiger shark.
They a little bit.
They can be.
They're aggressive.
They're not the nicest one you want to.
You want to show up.
And then he was a junior juvenile when
it was still a good,
like seven feet long,
seven years,
about seven feet long,
but he was young and the young,
the one that you don't trust the big old
shirt or you know,
they're wiser.
They know,
they check you out and things like that,
but the young ones had want a little bit
crazy so they're going to go more
towards you and they're going to go try
to do like curious bites,
which is mostly what happens most of the
time.
Which tribe bites as a curious spike and
so the discharge is in front of me and
he's charging me what his mouth open.
So my gun,
I'm,
I'm poking it.
I'm poking like the eyes,
I'm poking the gales and booking the
nose.
I'm trying to poke everything is going
to hurt him as much as I can and in a
very strong,
especially in the water.
So I'm really trying to like bang his
fricking gun as much as hard as I could
in his face and he doesn't back down.
He keeps like circling and he keeps
coming in for me and at some point I'm
like,
okay,
like something I'm going to have to
shoot it,
hoping that,
that,
you know,
I'm not going to miss because if I
missed and it's the only thing between
me and the shark poking it with the tip.
Yeah.
I'm just pulling in with a hip and then
you roll his eyes back,
which is when they are ready,
they're ready to bite.
And I'm like,
Oh shit.
I'm like,
mom,
I'm dying.
And I'm like,
okay,
well whatever,
you know.
So I'm like,
I'm like,
okay,
I'm going to try to aim and try to see
if I can shoot it.
And then my friends arrive,
he's heard you screaming,
what's,
do you have a fish?
I'm like,
oh,
there's a tiger shy behind you buddy.
And he's like,
oh crap.
He was like,
if my from Felix shoe,
I was like a 17 year old at the time and
you've never.
Rarely Spear Fisher was the first time
you're seeing a shark.
I promised his parents I would bring him
back in one piece and I'm like,
okay.
I'm like,
don't panic.
Everything is fine.
How deeply water,
like 15 feet of water was so shallow.
So I'm like,
put your back against mine and then
cover your half and if you come to cold,
spoke it and to shy came in a couple of
times.
And then,
because we were too,
it was like,
Eh,
whatever.
He just left.
He didn't like that,
that he was out numbered.
And I'm like wow.
So when I was alone with the Chicago was
screaming in the water and that was like
calling my friends for help and uh,
nobody could hear me.
And then we went back to the boat.
Freeman of the water.
How far away can people hear you?
Not,
not to,
not,
not to buy 10 feet,
15 feet.
So it depends on the wave again in the
winds and everything like that,
but nobody could definitely hear me then
wanting to get back on the boat.
My friend,
I see my friend swimming towards the
boat and he screams tiger shark.
I'm like,
no shit,
dumb ass.
I'd be like screaming for your health,
but it has happened an hour and then you
get to the boat.
Then we left and the sharper like
cycling it was like,
Ooh,
that was really scary.
But in that situation again,
if I had shut the sharp too to save
myself,
it's.
I would have got the worst publicity
ever.
It's,
it's.
I just one thing I don't understand.
When did that happen?
Were sharks became something that are
protected in the public eye?
Because was it the governor of New York
that killed that shark when he was a
fishing somewhat with the governor.
The mayor,
one of those guys was a.
was sport fishing caught a shark and was
it the governor Cuomo,
very common in the states show fishing
boat.
They're edible.
I've had Mako shark and restaurants
before,
but something happened,
something changed.
I think it was when there was all this
awareness about shark fin soup.
Yeah,
there it is.
Andrew Cuomo.
He caught 154 pound thresher shark and
everybody freaked the fuck.
Got It.
It's one,
it's one.
They realized that the Asians were
catching millions a day to make sure you
make a shark fin soup.
Yeah.
So it became,
instead of it being something that was
just another fish,
then it became something that's
protected and people with a very shallow
understanding of what a shark is.
We're freaking out about it.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's the Asians ruined it for everybody
else.
How dare you be careful today,
especially with crazy rich Asians,
number one in the box office.
Um,
I mean it's that,
that practice of chopping off the fence
and throwing the sharks back is
horrific,
but there's,
they're sustainable populations of some
sharks.
I mean apparently off of the coast of
California,
near Catalina island that the channel
islands,
lot of sharks out there
and then great white.
So she did populations of sharks rain
out and California's very height of
great whites.
Yeah.
Because the seal population became
really high.
And then because you know that the great
white shark population,
it takes more time to grow.
Now we're at a stage where days a shit,
tons of lionfish,
and now there's a lot of great white do.
But great whites are protected,
right?
Yes,
yes,
definitely.
Tiger sharks protected.
She's protected in a lot of places in
Florida.
I don't think you're allowed to eat.
It.
Depends where some marinas are very
funny about it.
And New York,
I went fishing in New York,
uh,
about a couple of months ago and a guy
was like cutting and Maaco and a dog and
nobody was,
seemed to be offended by it.
What people
that are on the water,
people that are Fisher people,
they,
they wouldn't be offended.
It's,
it's the casual person on the outside
that gets offended.
Yeah,
exactly.
But again,
you know,
that's.
What's this,
what the,
that's the double edged sward of,
of the Internet.
You know,
it gave a voice to everybody the.
Exactly.
But it's just like,
you know,
they remember that gorilla thing.
What was his name?
Yeah.
People are like,
oh,
this is terrible.
They should have never shut the gorilla.
They should have shut the mother
instead.
I'm like,
what we're saying when a surfer gets
bitten by a shy,
they're like,
oh,
it's his followers in this territory.
Like you shouldn't have like done
anything today,
so I can like put your mother and that
cage.
Would that gorilla then tell me which
one you're going to shoot.
My money's not.
My money's on our mother's Barbara going
to be in the gorilla.
Yeah.
I wish there was another way.
I mean,
I don't know that they needed to shoot
that girl.
I don't know enough about gorilla
behavior.
I would like to think that the gorilla
wouldn't have done anything to the baby,
but I don't know anything.
I don't.
I don't know much about the situation.
It's sad,
but if I have to choose
baby over gorilla,
I'm taking the baby every time I'm going
to save the baby.
Some fucking human.
It's.
Yeah,
but it's.
It's easy to be irrational when it comes
to that,
but this is
not you and you don't have any stake in
the game.
You're talking about it from the
sidelines and that's people talking
about sharks as people talking about
bears as people talking about a lot of
animals.
Yeah,
pretty much.
And this is why spear fishing hunting or
is this very well,
Hayden,
I guess around the world,
have friends that run a bear hunting
operation in um,
Alberta shout out to John and Jen saw
them this weekend in Calgary.
They are,
they run a bear hunting operation and
would they run a hunting operation?
But they spend a good amount of time
bear hunting.
Black bears and the black bear
population up there is incredibly dense.
There's so many of them.
They're everywhere and they decimate the
deer population.
They decimate the Moose,
the elk,
they eat all the babies and they
cannibalize each other.
I mean,
it's a,
it's a beautiful animals.
They're fascinating.
They're interesting.
I'm glad they're around,
but they're populations need to be
controlled.
There's a lot of them and they're
delicious.
And the,
all these things are like,
they fly in the face of reason for most
people.
They think if you're shooting a bear
that you're a trophy hunter,
like someone who's shooting a rhino or
something like that.
Someone who's a terrible person wants to
shoot something that's endangered.
There's.
They are as far from endangered as is
humanly possible.
They're not in danger by any stretch of
the imagination.
They live in dense forests and there's a
giant number of them and you can shoot
two of them up there.
They,
they,
they encourage you to shoot two of them.
They're trying to thin out the
population because of the effect they
have on the Angela.
It's up there,
but it's one of those animals that my
friend Steve Rinella calls them
charismatic megafauna.
It's cute.
Yeah,
well it's,
it's just we've made them into movie
characters and TV show characters and
people have this idea of what they are
based on just this,
this sort of image that gets portrayed
in the public and we accept this
narrative and I think that's happening
right now with sharks.
You know?
No one wants sharks to go extinct.
I think sharks are awesome.
They're cool,
but there are also edible like and if
there's a lot of them,
I've seen people catch Maaco sharks a
off of the coast of California and and
cut them up and make shark stakes up and
eat them and it used to be normal.
No one cared until.
I feel like within the last decade,
something happened in the last decade
that people became incredibly outrage.
When someone kills a shark.
I,
I actually think that people became
outraged when you kill anything,
but they're so hypocritical because
they're killing things left and right
with their pocket book.
They just don't know it.
They're killing things.
Their credit card,
they're killing things with cash.
If you buy fish at the store,
you're killing fish.
I don't care if you like to think you're
not.
You are.
You're supporting the fish industry.
You're supporting the killing of these
animals that are eating them.
It's a direct connection.
You're paying a supermarket,
hitman go out and do the workforce
one,
100 percent.
If you eat fish,
you cannot be against phishing.
If you eat meat,
you cannot be against hunting.
It's also the weirdness of it though.
I went to whole foods today on before I
came here to get some lunch and as I'm
walking through,
just because I was thinking that I was
going to have this conversation with you
today and I'm walking by these long
aisles of ice with these fish on it and
I could just point to one of those fish
and go,
hey,
give me that thing.
No connection whatsoever to where the
thing came from,
how it got there.
I just take it and I could bring it
here.
I probably should have just for effect,
just slap it down on the table.
Imagine the amount of grocery stores as
a country,
right?
A fish display,
which is completely full.
Well,
let's just imagine in this area there's
a whole foods that's about two miles up
this way and then if we go down the
street,
there's another one that a sprouts,
they have a fish section.
Then we go a little bit further down.
There's a Gelson's they have a big fix
fish section.
There's just fish all over the place,
but the ocean's pretty fucking
far from here.
I mean,
do you have to drive to get to the
ocean,
you know,
and they're not going to the ocean and
pulling these fish out themselves.
It's all coming from a giant commercial
boat to distributes it all throughout
southern California,
all throughout northern California.
All throughout.
Then you get into the middle of the
country.
That's where it gets really crazy.
If you're buying halibut and you're in
South Dakota,
where the fuck is that coming from?
You know,
Alaska probably.
Yeah.
You're not supposed to eat hell,
but if you live there,
I completely.
He should be close.
She'd be close though.
I mean I'm not,
I'm just kidding.
Eat you got to eat.
But it's,
we're weird.
People are weird.
And our connection with food,
olive dos boats,
you know,
they have um,
I mean the states is actually doing a
way better job than a lot of countries,
I must admit,
under control of fisheries.
But when,
when I see laws and regulations on small
little individual anglers,
your spear fisherman and then I see a
chocolate.
I can catch everything you want.
Dash just is just boils my blood to a
next level.
Well,
it's insane and in our lifetime the
population has decreased radically and
there's no better example than that than
the Tokyo fish markets,
you know,
the Tokyo fish market interview,
those guys and they talk about what it
used to be like when they just the
amount of tuna that they deal with and
the amount they deal with now it says
significant dip and this is within you
know,
40 years.
Like what is it going to be like 40
years from now?
And the estimates are that it's going to
be a radical decrease in the population
of almost selfish.
Yeah,
for sure.
But it's,
it's,
that's the problem.
People want to have access to
everything.
Now.
If we were put regulations on
everybody's fish,
like okay look everybody,
I know you want you salomon but it's
going to be close of January to me.
I know you want your halibut but you
can't eat it this year,
next year.
If we would be willing to live with
just.
I mean I think people would survive it,
that's for sure.
Because I don't think people will get
used to pretty much anything.
But then industry awards is worth so
much money that they were not willing to
do that.
It's not just the industry is worth so
much money.
Is it a certain people in certain
countries in particular where that is
all they have?
I mean there's certain people out there
where they,
they're dependent upon the ocean and
it's bounty for their survival and if
they can't sell fish and they can't buy
fish.
And we talked about individual Fisher
people that have boats and you know,
are doing it on their own small scale
commercial fishermen.
There's not a lot of room for error
there.
They're not making a ton of money.
Those are under problem.
Don't like the small family.
A commercial fishing boat.
They're not the problem.
I mean it's when you see,
when you see those guys bring it and you
know like the guy in the video earlier.
Yeah,
he just catching a big net is caching
like quite a bit of fish.
But your reality of things or ships,
foreign ships rating the entire ocean
would net sir like kilometers long.
Like an affiliate,
a net.
It is a mile long.
And you just catch everything.
You can't annette,
and then you like turtles,
turtles,
dolphins,
sharks,
everything.
Yeah.
And then it's not,
it's not.
They're picking Johnson.
Finally net lives in North Carolina.
Are you catching lobster and uh,
and then in two that are making a
problem,
but you'd have to have some regulations
that were accepted by all these
different countries too.
And that'll be a real difficult thing to
pull off to get these countries to
accept that they're going to lose money
and to do it in a timely fashion where
these,
these fish could actually bounce back.
It's not going to happen until there's
nothing left that's crazy.
And it's.
Everybody sees it.
Everybody is talking about it.
But
when you look at the sheer size of the
ocean,
the idea that we could fish the ocean
out is so crazy.
That's a lot of fish.
But when you see those commercial boats
and how the quantity of fish they
managed to take out of the ocean,
it's a lot of fish.
Is there any
talk about doing something about this?
Is there,
is there anything on the table?
Is there any discussion about regulating
the amount of fish these gigantic boats
can pull out?
Well again,
the US is trying to to,
to regulate that and they actually made
efforts that,
that proved to increase the amount of
fish or it's good they actually working
in the right direction.
But the problem is that still to this
day,
I'm not sure exactly how much,
uh,
how many nautical mile you have to be,
but a Russian or a Chinese foreigner
traveler is allowed to fish from the
coast of United States and international
water to just rate everything.
That is nothing he can do about it.
Who's going to regulate that?
The UN China is going to be like,
yeah,
sure buddy.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
Japan still killing whales,
you know,
they kill whales under the guise of,
um,
of science.
Have you seen how they do that at the
sea shepherd bus?
Those guys pretending that it was for
science and then they kill them,
sell them.
I mean,
it's really fucked up.
You know,
there was this,
the same exact problems going on in the
United States in the 18 hundreds.
A market hunting is what they were
calling it,
where they,
they devastated all the wildlife in
North America.
The buffalo population was almost
brought to extinction levels really
close.
Um,
there's still some wild herds that exist
in Mexico and there were,
some of them,
they exist in United States and now they
brought them back.
But to this day,
the majority of buffalo that live in
North America are all on private land.
The majority of them,
but at one point in time,
there's millions and millions of them
all throughout the country.
Elk there,
they've only been repopulated to a small
percentage of their original range.
I think it's something like 30 percent.
There's some animals that have thrived
like white tailed deer because,
um,
they live primarily in farmlands and
farmlands have gotten so huge that they,
they were essentially like farm animals.
Now.
It's very strange,
like when you think of white tail deer,
the places where they're the most
popular.
No,
that's actually reindeer.
That's a Caribou.
Yeah.
Caribou are these migrating deer that
live in Canada primarily and in Alaska,
and they migrate for hundreds and
hundreds of miles in these massive
herds.
They're very different and that,
you know,
unlike dear,
you'll see them like hundreds of them
moving together in one group in one line
across the Tundra,
but these animals that were in North
America,
not Alaska but north,
no,
not the,
the lower 48.
They were wiped out almost to nothing.
Antelope,
deer,
elk,
Buffalo.
They were almost all wiped out by market
hunting because this was back when we
didn't have refrigerators so people
would shoot these things and bring them
to market and people would go to market
and buy that meat and they would bring
it in on trucks.
I mean,
I guess they just have blocks of ice and
these trains and trucks and they would
bring in this meat and they killed
almost everything and it's short amount
of time,
like less than 100 years.
There was almost nothing left.
And then they instituted these laws
where it was illegal to sell wild game.
So if you buy elk,
like say in this country,
if you buy elk meat,
you're buying it from New Zealand,
you're getting it from.
It's actually enforced right now still.
Yeah.
There's.
There are some commercial farms.
I don't know what they sell.
I mean,
I think you can sell commercially raised
deer and elk in America,
but if you go to a restaurant,
most of what you're getting,
you're actually getting from New
Zealand.
Yeah,
but you can't go to the woods,
like say if you went to the woods and
you went and shot an elk,
that one up there and you tried to sell.
It's illegal to sell.
You can't sell that.
Meat is not a a marketable product.
It's something that has to.
You have to have a tag for it.
You have to pay for the tag and then it
has to be for your own personal
consumption or you can give it away to
your friends,
but you can't sell it.
Which is much of a bad thing.
It's the only way they had to eliminate
market hunting was the only way to bring
these populations back.
And then they had a enforce these very
strict conservation efforts.
And then here's the big one is I think
it's called the Pickman Robertson App,
whatever the Pickman Robertson's editors
is the name of that it.
What it is is it takes 10 percent of all
of the proceeds from hunting supplies
and gear and puts it to wildlife
conservation,
which is an enormous amount of money,
billions and billions of dollars.
So it goes to preserve habitat and
wetlands goes to reintroduce species
into places where they had been
decimated.
Like elk are now a inviolable numbers in
places where they were completely
extinct like in Virginia.
And Tennessee has them now as well.
And Kentucky I know has Hassam,
Pennsylvania has them.
And at one point in time there was none
there,
like up until just a few decades ago,
if it's,
if,
if things or actually handle and they're
responsible and smart way we can.
There is a way to save everything.
It's.
The problem is,
is the United States like the United
States is like,
it's,
it's on land,
it's controllable,
you know,
it's our,
it's,
it's within these boundaries of this.
This one country,
you know,
the control is accepted when you're
talking about the ocean
will be really difficult to get other
countries to agree to that kind of
strict management that brought back
wildlife in North America to do that to
the ocean.
But if they did do that to the ocean
mean maybe everything could bounce back.
Let me.
A few states.
Florida is definitely one of them where
do looking very closely to what's going
on and then they have closed seasons and
things like that and actually makes it
really nice and big difference.
But again I think the problem is not
coming from that department is coming
from again,
like deep trawling and commercial
foreign commercial fishing net.
It's just a big industry things.
It is
Florida for sport.
Fishing is a giant industry.
People go there every year to grouper
fish and fish for tarpon and you know
there's,
there's a lot of fishing in Florida and
it's probably a pretty significant part
of their economy.
Yeah,
I,
I think I read somewhere that actually
the number,
the number of jobs in a recorder of
recreational fishing was higher than in
commercial fishing in estates.
Wow.
I believe I read that somewhere,
the number of jobs.
So,
so the number of sacred most jobs.
So like selling fishing rods and lawyers
and guiding
born butters,
things like that.
Exactly.
That kind of makes sense.
So the commercial also,
I mean the biggest problem with
commercial fishing is I went to um,
actually went to Taiwan last last year
and it was helping them,
finding government and giving them a
proposal and how they can change the law
to make the fisheries better and ever
explained it to me now.
Like they have those ships and they hire
people from the Philippines or from
Indonesia and then they put them on a
ship for six months.
They take your passport and they're
getting paid like nothing.
Literally nothing.
And all they do all day long is they
catch tuna,
it gets,
you know,
the kitchen and the kitchen for like 14
hours a day.
And then that's it.
And that'll bring a tuna backs and they
sell it,
you know,
the problem is
people are fucking up so many different
parts of the world so fast.
It's hard to like go well we got to
really put it all aside and concentrate
on the fish.
No,
for sure.
That's again,
there's a lot of money and a lot of
people depending on it.
But then at some point we're going to
have to realize,
hey,
there's no fish.
So it's,
we're more people so we're going to have
to turn herself on,
on them and then.
But people are going to change their
ways or do anything unless he being
told.
Sorry,
there's no more fish.
How long have you been doing this now?
Full time.
About three years.
And have you noticed a difference in
three years?
Uh,
depends where.
But yeah,
some places definitely.
There's some when I'm traveling
different places what I've been.
And the third time that I would,
a third time before time I was coming
back,
I could see there was even less and less
fish.
They didn't mean to Terrainian is a
disaster.
Mediterranean,
there's literally nothing left in place.
What will happen,
and it's again,
that's another example where this has
been overfished for so many years.
They don't allow spearfishing there,
but a commercial fishing boats is
allowed to catch as many tuners they
want for tuna.
I mean it's pivoting easily.
Yeah.
Anthony Bourdain did something in Italy
and they.
There were so little fish that they were
actually throwing frozen fish into the
water,
like frozen octopus into the water and
they wanted him to pretend to catch
these frozen activists.
Instead,
he made a mockery of it and showed the
guy throwing the frozen fish into the
water,
frozen octopus into the water.
I'm not surprised if you catch a fish in
Greece.
You can sell it for like 100 year old
because there's no fish,
no fish.
There's definitely no fish,
but people won't change their ways until
you tell them so he can have you kenny
anymore.
And then I'd be like,
ah,
I guess I have to make an effort now.
Fuck.
So what would be the solution?
I mean,
can they,
is there a way to commercially raised
fish that's viable?
It's like they do with the cattle
industry.
Well,
I'm,
I'm actually going to the Marshall
Islands in October and I'm going to
visit this.
Um,
the Marshall Islands,
the Marshall Islands are those middle of
the Pacific in the middle of nowhere.
That's my thing.
And I know it's near straight or
something like that.
Know it's near Papa New Guinea and that
type of area.
Careful the people over there.
Oh that's fine.
I don't have much meat and like the
appetizer,
but they have some going to visit a farm
that is sustainable and everything.
It was any new Guinea people listening
to that.
I'm joking around.
People get so outraged.
Who's motherfuckers calling us all
cannibals.
Is that where it is?
Show me where it is again,
right there.
Where your,
where your Arrow is.
Oh my God.
That is ridiculous.
Don't go there.
So they told me that I'm going to visit
it.
I'm going to see is you just have to be
really careful because again,
if they leaks into the ocean and it
contaminates are fish and if some of
them escaped creates problems.
So it's kind of problems.
Does it create.
You can have a captive one.
So basically it's going infect the other
fish diseases or diseases is
the get when they're in captivity,
taking it all sorts of stuff.
So it's a lot like captive animals,
avian flu
and swine.
Yeah,
pretty much.
But in.
I'm fucking great.
Some really bad.
There was some,
some stories about some really bad fish
farms that are speeding damn with pig
stuff and it's just,
again,
it's all about being,
being responsible.
We did a podcast recently about cwd c,
d chronic wasting disease is a disease
that's spreading amongst a deer in this
country and they think a lot of it is
coming or some of it is coming from
deere farms.
They have these deer farms and all these
animals are eating off the same food and
they escape and then they spread it and
then there's an incubation period and
mean it exists in the wild and it exists
in deer farms.
So it's like.
It's very complicated.
But.
So they have a similar
issue with fish then?
Yeah,
they do actually.
And it's.
It's pretty bad,
but it's.
What kind of diseases do they get?
I wouldn't know what type of deal they
have.
It's just.
I'm not really familiar with fish
diseases to be honest,
but what that term is definitely like
some fish have cancer.
That's it's bad.
What does the term
zoonotic?
Is that the term when it leaves and
makes the jump to humans?
The diseases.
Are there any.
Yeah,
that's what like avian flu is and swine
flu.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Disease.
It makes it jump to humans.
Is there any diseases in fish that make
the jump to humans
apart from parasites?
The only thing you can take of that
human can actually get.
And parasites are pretty rare with ocean
fish.
Right.
It's more common with freshwater fish
farms.
We can see warm sometimes,
but you just discard them and then
that's fine.
They're not going to kill you.
They're just going to take a little
funky,
but who you've eaten worms that came out
of fish for sure.
Right.
Most of probably I just probably don't
know it when I cut the fish raw cut a
pretty small,
so I make sure that it's nothing.
Know you look to see the worms.
Yeah,
you can see them.
Can you get in your body to where it
starts growing for a little slice?
Um,
I'm not going to try,
do you know?
But uh,
no.
Will you cook the fish?
They all dead.
So that's why if you freeze it,
that's what a lot of people freeze
there.
So she made before eating it.
Yeah.
To
do that with pigs and a lot of animals
in this country too,
but there's two types of tricky gnosis
apparently.
Maybe there's more,
but there's two very specific kinds of
tricky gnosis.
One that if you freeze it'll die.
And this is a trick,
tricky gnosis that comes from an animal
that's from the southwest of the United
States,
but then there's trick gnosis that comes
from animals that's in the northern
territories in Canada in particular,
like bears,
Alaska and that stuff.
You could freeze it,
it doesn't matter.
It doesn't even kill it when you freeze
it.
So you have to cook it.
It has to be cooked to 100.
I think it's 160 degrees,
some 147,
162 recommended temperature.
You have to kill those little fuckers.
Yeah.
Otherwise you just.
It just gets into your muscle tissue.
I have some friends that caught.
It's horrific.
Oh,
that's bad.
Yeah.
You like your whole body's like in
because it's literally.
They're borrowing their way into your
body.
I don't think you have something bad,
bad and fish.
I mean,
maybe that's why I'm skinny.
Who knows
for.
Well,
maybe you just eating fish all the time.
It's probably pretty lean stuff,
but also free diving.
You burn when you go spearfishing.
You burn about between a thousand and I
think 1300 calories an hour.
Why?
So?
He wouldn't lose weight goals.
Pivoting really 1300 calories an hour.
That's incredible.
It's very,
very intense.
Wow,
that's amazing.
That's what you would think.
A lot of people listening to this like,
oh,
I could eat so much food.
I'll just go free diving,
but you also don't eat food,
which is the Marshall Islands.
Oh,
Jesus starts to blow that thing up.
We've shown that a million times.
That's the crazy nuclear bomb testing
area.
That is the nuttiest shit ever.
You see that as miles high water
spraying up into the sky.
So maybe the fish you're going to have
like,
oh yeah,
you're going to have fish that can read
your mind to get.
I know you're coming.
What do you spear phishing for in the
Marshall Islands?
We're just going to be visiting a farm
and yeah,
so it's Kinda good.
I have a lot of people asking me for or
for alternatives and what it can do and
what did you eat?
And so this is one of the possible
alternatives that they have these farms.
Exactly.
So I'm going to check it out and make
sure that it's legit.
And then is it possible that they could
reintroduce fish into the ocean?
Like stock the ocean because that's what
they do.
Some lakes,
like uh,
I used to go fishing at this lake in
Boston and um,
the restock it every year with rainbow
trout.
Yeah.
That's actually by my leg when my
parents have a good crunchy.
How's it do that to you?
And it works.
The only problem that we see with that
for like an ocean fish would be I'm
thinking because they never had
predators captivity,
that that may be in my habits revival
problem after that,
but maybe they can learn it.
I don't know.
Yeah.
The strong smart survive.
Right.
You still better that if you know,
if there's 10 thousands of survivors
still good.
It's better than.
Yeah.
I wonder what would have to do.
I wonder if it's even possible to,
to restock something as big as the
ocean.
It's just being fished so quickly and
that's,
that's the biggest problem.
But there are solutions.
It's just people have to be willing to
talk about it and right now that's the
biggest problem with the same situation
as what the Wall Street Journal when
people and trying to talk about food
searching and mentioning alternative,
but like they're like,
we don't eat fish,
we don't eat seafood.
No,
that's not true.
And don't you think that it's the optics
though?
I mean what they're concerned with is
not.
It's not that it's rational,
it's that they don't want any.
That's what it is.
So a person like you,
although what you're doing is if you
explain it and you look at it
objectively,
it's very rational,
but they're not trying to be rational
with they're trying to do is avoid any
conflict.
Like there was a guy who is a nascar
driver,
okay.
And he lost a sponsor recently for some
racist stuff that his father said 30
years ago.
This is how crazy people are getting.
Thirty years ago his father used a
racial slur and because of that,
this guy who wasn't even alive when this
happened or maybe he was alive,
maybe he was seven years old or some
shit,
he lost the sponsor.
Man,
it's one of the companies are such
cowards,
like they're so terrified because of
social media,
because people are so willing to protest
and there's a bunch of fuck heads out
there.
They just get a thrill off of getting
people fired and of getting things
canceled and of like exercising action
and seeing a result.
All they're doing is pushing buttons.
It's not that they've thought about this
and like,
Hey,
is this guy really responsible?
Should we really blame him for something
his father did 30 years ago and that's
ridiculous.
What we should do is nothing just let it
go.
I mean,
unless this guy is like some sort of
white supremacists are some racist
himself and he's not,
we should just do nothing,
but that's not.
That doesn't.
That's not fun.
What's fun is getting a rush,
a power trip out of action,
like clearly there should look.
If you find a real racist,
something,
someone who's doing something actively
to harm other people simply based on
their ethnic origin or the color of
their skin,
but yeah,
that's terrible.
You should talk about that.
That should be eliminated from our
society.
Real,
real racism,
but that's not what this is.
What this is is people deciding that
they're going to take action and then
Nascar being a pussy about it or this
company being a pussy about it and
that's the same thing that's happening
with you.
It's not.
This is not a rational decision like
they should look at it and go,
wow,
what an interesting way to get your
fish.
Like how many of these people that made
this decision actually eat fish?
I would bet it's most.
I bet it's most
people should understand also that by
refraining people to talk about it,
you being part of the problem.
Yes.
This is why things have been so bad for
so many years because nobody wants to
talk about it.
They all want to eat it.
They just don't want to know where it's
from,
but no one's looking at things long
term.
All they're looking at potential short
term income loss.
So what the Wall Street Journal or the
Washington Post or whatever,
whatever paper it is,
what they're worried about.
They're worried that someone's gonna
come along and say the Wall Street
Journal support.
Was It Wall Street Journal?
The Wall Street Journal supports a
mass extinction of fish.
They can just reframe it and some
outrageous,
unrealistic non the accurate way.
Well,
people need to chill out to understand
honestly.
Um,
when it come from
in a sense that especially like the
millennials or whatever we all born
with.
You know,
we had a bunch of toys with China and,
and wouldn't you shit about dad?
We ate whatever we won.
Nobody gives a shit about that.
We had fricking process food.
Nobody cared about it.
We had hot dogs and nobody was saying
anything about it.
And then we all reach like,
or mid twenties and Ellison and we've
been taught,
but everybody,
oh by the way,
you know everything,
like all you barbies or they're very bad
environment.
Oh you know what,
by the way,
like the hot dogs,
you've been eating every bathroom
environment and you like,
we live in an era when being told that
everything we're doing Israel and it's
hard.
It's hard for somebody that lives in
Missoula city that doesn't know anything
else to be like,
oh yeah,
you know,
what's,
what shoe,
I'm going to stop eating this that I've
been eating for the last 20 years just
because somebody told me.
So
somebody had a very funny tweet about
starbucks,
about als.
You know,
the Dino California eliminated straws.
Yep.
And starbucks had this whole thing
about,
you know,
big sign about how we're doing our part
for the environment.
We're eliminating straws.
And then on the,
you know,
the tweeted said,
um,
okay.
So you're just putting plastic lids on
your coffee cups.
Yeah.
And what happens with them.
And then starbucks,
it's an o Dot d.like
you got fucking fixed and shit just
because you get rid of this draws.
You got plastic lids everywhere you go.
Those God damn starbucks lids are
littered on the street.
They're everywhere.
But is this actually,
this is a perfect example because it
shows exactly this bit of action.
The people are like,
they have either a very small action and
makes them feel better or they like to
point out two fingers.
If somebody else you with your Straw.
Exactly Straw.
Now it,
it's,
it's this,
this,
just the way people are dealing with
that.
They've been told that everything you've
been doing since Jay kids are bad.
So now they're like,
no,
but,
but look at her.
She's fishing,
she's evil.
It's just,
it's just.
I think it's that as soon as the way to
people or handling the fact that they've
been told that everything is wrong,
that they're trying to be like,
no,
I made my effort.
I made a facebook post this morning
saying that I wasn't getting Straw,
so I'm green.
California seems to be the first state
to limit plastic straws.
All restaurants.
Wow.
Yeah.
Is that not as a pass,
but that's the.
It's been proposed governor Jerry Brown.
I just had.
How can it be so difficult?
She'd be like,
look,
plastic is a problem.
You use something else.
You know,
one thing that they,
um,
I don't know,
maybe I saw this with Europe or the US
fund this on your page,
that there's a,
a new that they use
for water runoff before it goes into the
ocean is his giant net that catches all
this plastic particles.
Was that on your instagram page?
Know that?
It's really interesting.
Someone has invented this cover that's
like a,
it's like a filter that as the water's
going through,
it catches all the stuff that would
ordinarily be washed out to sea.
And so it basically over these storm
drainage pipes,
he's enormous.
Pious is this huge net so the water can
still go through it,
but just shows you like this insane
amount of debris and garbage that would
have ordinarily just been washed out to
sea and the catching it in these nets.
It's not everything but it's a start and
it's not going to make up for the FEC
and cruise ship that's dumping things
just right off shore.
It's crazy.
I did not know that.
That was the case.
Yeah,
you,
it's,
it's legal to.
And that's the worst part of it.
But
you spearfish,
spearfish,
because I'm the bad guy.
So
would you want to do is you want to
spear fish and you want to raise
awareness that you want to continue to
live this life.
So what you're trying to do along the
way is trying to figure out how to make
a living while you're doing it.
Yeah,
I do.
I'm,
I'm going to want to write a book.
At some point
I might ask you how old you are.
I'm 31.
So this is an age where people are like,
oh Jesus,
you're in your thirties,
should have your shit together by now.
That's a lot of people think you know,
it's,
you're in that area were like,
you should have,
you should have your career in order.
She's thinking about settling down,
having a family.
You should start your 401k and you
should have all this stuff in line and
you're out there fishing,
stabbing fish.
No,
I don't.
I don't mind that.
I don't think my,
my age is an issue.
It's
no,
I don't think it's an issue either.
I'm just saying that in the path from
graduating high school to go into
college to become an a person that's 31
years old.
I mean a lot of people compare
themselves in a very sort of foolish
way.
They compare themselves with other
people,
like how much stuff have these people
accumulated,
how much you buy.
But it was,
for me,
it was,
it was a crucial step of my life to be
able to take a step back.
I want to take a step back of all of
that and be like,
okay,
Whoa,
whoa.
Like I've been telling the same thing
since I'm born about what I should want,
about what I should do about,
you know,
about what me.
Exactly.
You know,
it's like when I was one of his seven
years old,
I look at my mom and I said,
you know,
mom,
when I grow up,
I'd rather have like a job that I don't
like when I make a shit ton of money,
not a job.
I love what I make,
nothing.
I was seven.
I told that to my mother and my mom was
like,
what did I do wrong?
Well,
that's a rational thought with kids
because then when I quit my job,
then my mom was the one being like,
what are you doing dad?
You have no security in life and blah,
blah blah.
And I'm like,
well,
sorry.
It's,
it's,
it's good.
I need,
I need to step back.
I need to look at everything around me.
I need to look at society in each to
look how things work.
And I,
I want to make sure that when I'm,
when I'm in it,
it's because I actually,
I know what I want
and I'm at,
I don't like being told what to do.
Right.
So that's,
that's kind of what I'm doing and
figuring out my own thing and the
fingernail,
what's,
what's important for me in what my real
values are and I don't think you can
discover depression.
You really are by staying in your nine
to five by not knowing anything and
being unhappy and not being able to go
outside of your comfort zone.
Right.
Comfort zones,
the big word,
right?
Because it's comforting that you get
that check every week.
It is,
but it's fine.
It's numbing.
You have kids,
you have this and that,
but it's people that tell me like,
oh,
I used to encourage us to have done that
were,
oh,
I envy you life so much.
And like,
well,
when I first quit my job,
I live in my fricking car for awhile
because I didn't have a place to stay
and neither no money to sustain myself.
Did you really live in your car?
Yeah,
I did for awhile.
How long?
Like if I like a month,
something like that and what?
It was like sporadic in my car.
Or did you shower somewhere?
No,
no,
I have friends so I was like,
showering is also beaches,
the showers and the beach,
but I wasn't sure
when that was happening.
How old were you at the time?
Twenty three years ago.
So 20.
So you're 28.
You were you like,
what the fuck am I doing with my life?
I'm living in my car.
Yeah,
but I haven't.
but I felt I felt free and I never
regret in my life.
And that's okay.
Well you are courageous if that's the
case because a lot of people would panic
me included.
It's I guess you courageous in a way
regarding the fact that you're sleeping
in a car,
but if he unhappy with your life,
why?
Why keep going with it?
Well,
that's what you're saying is logical,
right?
But logic is not how most people live
their lives.
What you're saying is like your
romantic,
like you're saying,
I want to live my life with passion and
I want to follow my interests and I
don't mind living in my car and
showering at the beach.
I don't mind.
I'm fine with that.
Most people are not fine with that.
Most people would be insecure and they
would be scared of the future and they
would want some sort of stability and
that's,
that's what courageous about your,
your decision because one of the things
that like,
um,
I was talking with people about you
before I did this podcast and the
question from everybody's like,
how does she make a living?
I'm like,
oh no,
I'm not sure.
I'm like,
she,
I guess she's a professional spear,
Fisher person.
I go,
but I don't know how you make money
doing that.
I'm like,
maybe a guide.
People take people out
sometimes.
Very rarely.
I'm afraid of having a structure too.
So why don't only give private lessons.
I'm a freediving instructor so I don't
really.
I give lessons once in a while.
I have contracts here in there.
I'm not right now.
I reached a point where I'm not,
I'm not rich,
but I'm not starving either.
Right,
and I'm,
I'm,
I'm kind of happy about it than I
actually do believe is going to lead to
some something,
but lead to choose something that,
to a job that I think is going to be,
you know,
what I'm trying to giving conferences
around than I think that's,
that's something that really,
really interesting.
Conferences like this woman's
empowerment thing.
You were going to talk?
Yeah,
pretty much.
Just without all the shit going behind
it.
Well that was just one and I'm sure
people love a story about someone who's
following their passion because there's
so many people out there that really
desperately want to do that.
They just don't know how to do it or how
to get the courage to do it or they get
stuck with a mortgage or maybe they have
a family and responsibilities or maybe
they have loved ones that are taken care
of and they can't.
And so when they hear about someone
who's going for it,
either they're jealous of you and they
hate on it,
and they say that stupid,
that girl's a fool,
blah,
blah blah.
Or they go,
God,
I wish I could do that.
Those,
those are the two.
Depending upon the mindset of the person
that's watching you,
that's going to be their reaction.
I completely agree.
Well,
I have,
I had a TV show coming on,
have my coo book coming on.
What's the TV show?
I have a TV.
It's going to be in French,
but it's,
it's about,
I'm going to be traveling around the
world and fishing with.
I'm not even sure I'm ready to talk
about that.
Um,
whoops.
Was a TV show is going to be fun.
And I'm starting with my sister just
graduated from fashion design in London
and we're just starting.
I'm a bathing suit company with recycled
fabric.
Oh,
okay.
So what do I have a few things that
might pipeline.
I'm not,
I don't like being bored.
I don't like.
I know it seems like it.
Like,
oh,
like I'm free spirited and I traveled
around,
but I'm,
I'm still a very ambitious person and I
do want to achieve.
Things are going to make me proud.
It's not always,
you know,
it's not.
I didn't quit a bit thing to,
to become a hippie and live on the beach
and no,
she's rest of my life.
No,
I just,
I quit my job to live and build my life
in my career the way I want it to end in
a way that was making me proud and
happy.
So this is pretty much what I'm,
what I'm,
what I'm doing right now.
It's very admirable.
It really is.
It's,
and it is really brave because you're
not going to get a whole lot of
reinforcement from other people.
I'm sure you probably didn't.
Probably wearing a lot of people that
were telling you,
you go for a girl,
go sleep at the beach.
Yeah,
senior car.
Yeah.
You don't have a shower who needs a
shower,
you don't know where your food is coming
from.
Foot care,
but it's also the group of people were
like,
Oh yes,
it's a good idea.
And then a second you turn around and
you're like,
am I getting wow,
people love to talk shit.
But it's even in my hardest moments when
I was broke or anything like that,
I never regretted it.
Not once second I told myself I made a
wrong decision.
So I guess it gets signed.
Well the good thing is you are doing
something that's so soul sucking
that anything seems like it's,
it's,
it's worth.
I really
found myself in situations when I was
like,
Ooh,
I'm actually an asshole.
It was like,
okay,
I'm kind of have to work on that as a
lawyer.
No,
even like in,
in,
in this life,
you know,
especially when you know,
filming a documentary in Africa and
different places where you know,
you have no food and you're like,
I have a table of people that were
sharing like a can of tuna in between
for people.
And you're like,
like,
yeah,
let's share.
I'm happy to share.
And it's just like,
I just want to like push it around and
digging it.
It's you,
you're discovering yourself and
sometimes you don't always like what you
see and it's.
But it's,
it's good,
it's just,
it's what it's for,
you know,
it's,
you've looked at yourself and then I
would have never discovered a type of
person that I am when I'm starving,
run a nine to five job unless you're
starving.
Right?
Exactly.
How many people ever are right?
Not definitely not that many.
And again,
this was the thing that shocked me the
most and I think it's also what touches
people the most about
Africa has been one of them is people
super close with each other.
People are really nice and you're really
focusing on things and it's,
you're like,
wow,
I won that.
I want to keep doing that.
But then you know,
you spend your money there and then you
spend a month in New York City and you
forget everything.
It takes literally a week to forget
everything.
You know.
Another hard thing would be if you tried
to relay your experiences on a
television show,
it would be edited down to even if it's
a one hour show with commercials,
it becomes 44 minutes and you're just
not going to be able to get all of that
can be very hard.
I told him that I was not interested in
to doing anything scripted and I told
them if I want to do a TV show,
if I'm puking I,
I wanted there.
If I'm crying,
If I hate it,
if I'm crying for my mommy to come pick
me up.
I wanted there to.
Because I think it's.
It's.
That's what.
That's the beauty part about those
travels and that's what needs to be
shown.
I think
that would be a real reality show,
but the reality of reality shows is most
of them,
or at least planned out if they're not
scripted.
Totally,
and you could tell you,
you can tell when people are like,
well,
we gotta fix this gas pump,
but we're not going to get this boat
started.
Such bad actors you see to their face,
you could smell it when they're acting.
It's just like.
But that's what it was.
The beauty of the Anthony Bourdain show
actually it was all about,
wouldn't
do that.
I mean,
that's why when they threw the frozen
octopus in the water,
he was mocking them.
Exactly.
But it's,
I mean,
I understand why a lot of people see
that in me.
I'm a girl and sometimes a little bit
girly and things like that and people
were like,
oh,
like,
she wants us to be in a TV show and do
this and do that.
And it's,
it's,
I,
I get why,
why people would think that.
But it's,
it's.
I mean,
if you pass five minutes,
you're going to be licensed.
What you're trying to do is relay your
passion for something.
And when people really,
like,
I've struggled with that with bow
hunting because I've done some things on
camera.
I did some,
uh,
a film last year for under armour.
We went elk hunting.
But part of me is like not everything
should just be broadcast.
Not Everything should be fair.
Sometimes life should just be
experienced,
especially for someone like me who's,
I think I'm overexposed in the first
place.
I would be better off doing less things
publicly,
so that's one that I've decided to do
less of publicly,
but part of me wants people to know that
there's a satisfaction to like bow
hunting in particular is very,
very difficult.
It's very hard to do.
It takes intense practice.
It takes a lot of physical exercise.
You have to be able to run up the hills,
you have to have endurance because
you're climbing through the mountains
all the time and then it's hard to do.
It's hard to find the animals.
It's hard to get close enough to shoot
one.
You have to be able to execute when the
moment is there.
It's very difficult to shoot an animal
with a bow and Arrow,
especially long distance.
I mean you have to have an extreme
amount of proficiency before you can
ever pull that off under high stress
situations.
So part of me wants to relay that there
is a misconception about what people see
when they think of hunting.
They think of cruelty and they think of
someone who doesn't respect nature and
they think of,
they think of this,
um,
they think of this a abusive
relationship that humans have with
animals instead of the way I look at it,
which is you have this deep
understanding of the food chain and this
food chain exists.
Whether you're there or not is food
chain exists with bears and wolves and
mount minds and deer and elk and all
these animals are struggling for
survival and all you do is interject.
You step in for a little bit and you
take your part in the food chain and in
and in turn you also give out all this
money that goes to conservation is money
that goes to conservation,
ensures that this opportunity to be
there for other hunters in the future
and ensures that the populations of
these animals will stay healthy and it
ensures that they'll be monitored by the
proper fishing game and wildlife
biologists and all these different
people that are going to ensure that
these animals are this,
this environment and this experience is
preserved.
And The wild habitat that these animals
enjoy will be preserved and it's for
people,
it's very conflicting,
you know,
for people it's,
it's,
it seems almost hypocritical that you
could say that you love these animals,
but you also want to eat them.
Yeah.
But that's,
that's not what's,
what's,
what's the hybrid thing to do is to say
that you left them and then buy them for
grocery store and not caring how they
got there.
That's when you being ridiculous.
What's the problem is that's been
available for so long.
We're used to it.
Like if there was just a machine that
you could go to where you could just get
your money from this machine.
You talked to somebody about hunting and
then they put their fingers in ears and
I'm like,
oh,
I don't want to hear anything.
And you're like,
what?
Well,
it's the same when you go to Mcdonald's,
the Wall Street Journal approached you
with phishing spear phishing.
It's the same thing.
It's not,
it's not a well thought out,
rational argument.
They're worried about outrage.
And in this day and age it's very easy.
Like I,
I had a picture,
I put up the other day of a target that
I have in my backyard with some arrows
in it and all these vegans are attacking
me for shooting fucking target.
You know,
it's crazy.
I mean they know I'm practicing and I'm
getting ready to shoot animals,
but all they're doing is there's no
animal there.
It's fucking rubber to rubber elk and
they're getting angry because that's
what people like to do.
They like to express outrage and they,
they talk too much.
There's too much expression.
Take it from someone who does talk too
much.
Me,
I talk way too much,
but people there,
they're not considering their,
what they're doing.
They're just doing it and you're not.
You don't change people's opinion by
being an asshole online.
You just get everyone to realize you're
an asshole.
Two,
I've got a bunch of Vegan following me
now because I took the time to respond
to their concerns and now they actually
got it,
but how can we make improvement when
when you have an one side and a bunch of
people that only want to do is scream,
scandal,
everything they see and then in year
decide the people that matters.
I have a strong voice or if you care to
talk about everything because they
scared of that first group and then by
doing that we're doing nothing.
I've been toning down a lot.
My instagram,
I stopped posting fish with blood on it
with things like that because people
just don't want.
I don't want to see it and I know I
don't have a choice to do that because
again,
if you what
but what percentage don't want to see
it.
This is the thing.
I mean if someone eats fish,
if they'd like Sushi and then they get
upset when they go to your instagram
page and you've got to have a spear
through a tuna
you're on,
you're almost.
You're educating them and a lot of ways
and the people that do get upset,
even though you hear their voices and
the voices are a loud minority.
I mean you have.
How many followers do you have on
instagram?
Eighty $4,000.
Same thing.
I think about 84,000 people looks like
in a room.
That's a giant number of people.
Now imagine 50.
Those people are screaming assholes.
That's what you have.
True.
It's a small percentage.
The number of people that see it and
they're rational adults,
they know that in order to kill a tuna,
there's going to be some blood.
There's no bloodless method for killing
it tonight.
It doesn't exist,
but also the weird thing is that in a
way I understand the outrage on a
certain level.
Like when I went deer hunting for the
first time in New Caledonia and last
October and it was not.
Would boast always with actual gun and
when I shot the deer,
so I cry.
I was like,
oh my God,
I killed Bambi and it was so bad and I
give there.
It was like,
oh,
it was all cute and everything and like,
okay,
and then it was dead and then I carried
it on my back and we walked back to the,
to the house and then they started
cutting it in pieces and it started
looking like meat and my guilt when
completely away,
completely away.
And I was like,
wow,
how much of a hypocrite can I be that
I'm crying because I killed fricking
Bambi.
Like actual physical tears going down my
face.
And then a second I see a piece of meat.
I just got excited.
I'm like,
we're going to be burgers elicited and
it sits fish is a little bit easier
because a lot of us have seen a whole
fish has kids,
you know,
you put a whole in a table so that the
Gore is a little bit less there,
so it's more about the blood than seen
actual fish dead.
But I bet I get it.
How am I know it's bad.
But I,
I felt really,
really like in hypergrid after that.
I know,
I know that.
I mean,
I felt that I felt in a weird way,
I felt like a weird sense of loss the
first time I shot a deer.
Um,
but it went away when I started eating
it too.
And I never killed an animal before
that.
But I,
I had killed fish.
I've been fishing since I was a little
kid.
I love fishing,
but I didn't feel a connection with fish
the same way I felt a connection with a
mammal.
It's because it's closer to us,
you know,
our closer to our species.
Fish is like an alien thing that lives
in an alien world,
that breeze water.
But again,
the one that had like the human,
like eyes,
then I tend to fill a tuna is one of
them.
I tend
to,
I have,
I have a picture I have,
I have to show it to you.
If tuna eyes,
it's you,
like it's,
it looks,
it looks really like you can seek
suppression and,
and,
and their eyes.
That's when,
that's the second way people starting to
feel like,
oh,
I remember fear.
There's,
I think it's curiosity,
but I guess you can say from freaking
out because it knows you're going to eat
it.
It's anthropomorphization,
right?
We will look at animals a week.
See,
that's one of them just actually very.
That's kind of human light.
Well,
that fish is an asshole.
I can tell looking in his eyes.
What is that?
That's a duct to tutor.
Those teeth are amazing.
Yeah.
That's a pretty weird fish that Jeremy.
Hello folks.
So it's,
you know,
you can see like just like a little bit
wide on the outside and then just call
her and freaking out because
it's looking out at the air for the
first time.
It's like,
Holy Shit,
it's just another world up here.
Gosh,
actually see this.
Well for a second.
He was right there.
He's alive.
She's alive.
Yeah.
It's probably freaking out outside the
water.
Like what in the fuck is this?
Oh,
imagine if it was alive event that John
My ass,
my,
my hands would have of his gills.
So if it comes back alive it.
This is a very,
very strong fish.
Imagine,
look at it.
It looks like a tank,
but I mean imagine being a fish,
you live your whole life in the water
and then also in somewhat pulls you out
of it and you look into the and you're
like,
what is this and why can't I breathe?
Well,
at least I did it very quickly.
So that's the good thing about it.
Yeah.
But it's got to be a freakout and push
the brains like the size of your
fingernail.
Right?
But in life is Brian Pretty quickly?
What's that?
Life is Brian Pretty quick.
So would you do right in the dome?
So you killed them and if you don't you
shoot them and if you don't kill them on
a spot where the gun really?
Yeah.
You shoot tuna with a gun.
What?
A spear gun?
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
Spirits
Gangsta.
Lean sideways style.
Shoot him right there
because I know they club them.
They clubbed fish and they put them on
boats,
but I didn't know this shot him.
Sure you can.
But you should have underwater that says
how you do it.
What a spear gun.
You shoot them underwater.
Yes.
I get that.
And then when you get it on land,
what I do is,
well,
one,
what's most fishermen do you grab them
from the guild as,
sorry,
graphic content,
be weird.
And then you grab it,
right.
Given your knife it and a nice
intensely.
Right.
If you do,
if you go lion fishing or commercial
fishing,
what they do is they just throw it in
the boat and then dies like 16 hours.
And so it's,
we kill it as quick as possible.
Yeah.
And do you immediately throw them on
ice?
Yes.
You know what?
I didn't know
until you bleed it first.
You bleed it first,
you know when you eat,
when you eat.
I'm a Sushi or fashion.
It tastes fishy.
It's very often the blood that makes,
that makes that taste.
So every time we catch a fish you just
cut the girls,
you let him bleed.
And then that's the same with meat.
I just sat with me.
Yeah,
they,
the,
the uh,
butcher dear.
They'll hang it by its legs and cut it's
throat and got it.
And let everything with the meat bleed
out.
Yes.
Certainly dead fish,
you have to do it straightaway,
almost in the water if there's not too
many sharks around because the blood
coagulates very,
very,
very quickly and then it becomes too
late and then it changes the flavor of
the fish.
Yeah.
Because when you fill it out,
you cut it on the side and then when you
flip it,
there's just like blood everywhere and
then it did painting to me and then it
creates a team that it's not that good.
And I think that's one of the reasons
why they soak fishing milk.
It changes the flavor because I think if
I remember this correctly,
there's enzymes in milk that destroy the
harmful bacteria that causes fish to
taste fishy.
And I think they said that this works
also with meat and with chicken,
that there's a certain smell to chicken
in particular that when you get it,
like it's might smell a little.
What that is,
is this certain bacteria that's on the
surface of the skin and then if you soak
it in milk,
see if he could find that.
I remember I read that like really
recently.
Does it,
it,
uh,
helps odor free cooking when you're
doing fish shark even to.
I tried to,
yeah,
that was the only time I used the sharks
know you monster while I was in.
I'm in lunch hook in.
Um,
I,
I saw a guy was floating a shy and talk
in Long Island Long Island yet and then
um,
he was filling like a small Maaco
shotgun to ask him for peace and it
gives me a slub of.
I was like,
okay,
thank you.
So what court with my big piece of sharp
and what struck me was the smell.
It smell like meat.
You can,
you can smell the ammonia in it.
It was,
it was super strong.
And then I read on line and said put an
milligan lemon juice for 24 hours.
Did you do that?
Yes I did.
And a lemon juice would break it down.
Was it good?
Yeah,
that's good.
How do you cook it?
I just fried in a pan.
Do you have a special way that you like
to cook?
Fish?
Um,
it depends on which one,
but I really like lightly floured and
just icu it in olive oil and then I,
I cook it slowly and butter and
friendship with butter and everything.
Yeah.
Have you become like more into cooking
because you kill your own fish?
Opposite really?
I actually,
I mean opposite in a way that I always
love to cook and I got into spearfishing
because of cooking.
So this is what made me fall in love
with the sport is the fact that or the
lifestyle you can call it,
it's the fact that catching mountain
food,
I get access to two amazing fish and
seafood that is,
couldn't be more fresh and done.
There's a guy named Hank Shaw,
he's been on my podcast before.
He's an amazing chef and he,
uh,
he has a bunch of wild game,
a recipe books and he got into it
because he wanted the freshest
ingredients and he wanted wild game
ingredients as opposed to buying farm
raised or factory farmed food.
He wanted to be able to cook amazing
dishes from like say a wild pig that he
shot himself.
So he got into hunting because of that
and because of that it's,
it's very valuable for people that are
really interested in and cooking wild
game because he was a legit,
excellent chef before he ever got into
hunting and then getting into hunting
and now he writes books about it and
he's very,
very passionate about it.
So
I'm an interesting.
It was.
It was a very similar situation to me.
I literally got into it just pretty much
just for the food.
Actually the first two years when I
thought is pivoting ain't even likes
pivoting.
I wasn't scared of my own shadow for two
years.
I didn't like it.
I liked it the first time.
I liked it,
I liked the concept,
I liked what was behind it.
I fell in love with,
with catching my own food and cooking
after and all of that was publishing
itself.
It took me awhile.
So you were still nervous about it?
I was extremely nervous,
extremely like struggling
to breathe and every time I was going
for spear fishing trip,
I couldn't sleep for a month.
I was literally imagining myself being
treated by a shark.
And this and that.
And it was,
it was never.
My trips never been about that even
though it was completely petrified of
them.
I've been lost at sea,
which was pretty shitty day.
I might say.
What happened two years ago?
Um,
I was in Mexico and I was with friends
and I was,
I was so angry.
I hated the guy so badly what happened?
So I jumping in the water with a friend
of mine,
I've never speakers before.
And we're,
we're in the water in there.
No,
no,
he never did anything.
He's just like,
oh,
I want to look around and I see what are
you doing?
And then I see the water.
It's pretty deep and you can't see the
bottom.
And then the boats are going further and
further and further and further and
further.
And my friend is like,
oh,
what's going on?
I'm like,
nothing.
Nothing.
And I'm like,
okay,
we're going to start swimming from the
shore right now for the shore.
Yeah,
for sure.
So start swimming.
It was like,
it would have been doable.
It was like maybe a good like five
miles,
maybe fucking shore was five.
It was far.
It was like I would have done it.
It was definitely been after Darwin had
reached the shore,
so I'm trying not to panic.
My heart is like pounding in my chest,
in my throat.
It's true thing.
Wait drifting away for no reason.
And some of the boat,
the captain that we hired,
that was American actually.
What do you do to start drinking and not
paying attention to you?
Oh wait.
And then we're stocks.
I told my friend Akila swimming.
We swam for about an hour,
an hour and a half and then a bowl
passes by.
So I started screaming and yelling and I
had my brewery.
Luckily I was swimming it and it passed
next immediate wave at me like,
hi.
I'm like,
Nah.
how do I go?
Completely nuts and bolts stuff and they
pick us up and I tried to explain and my
completely nexus in Spanish that we've
been trending at sea and it seemed like
on the boat is like right there,
super far away and they drop us to the
boat.
The guy is asking me for money.
I'm like,
I'm lost at sea.
My wetsuit think I'm carrying.
Took you to the boat is asking you for
money.
They got the guy that picked me up.
It was asking me for money for tip,
for rescuing me in the middle of the
ocean.
I was like,
sorry,
I don't have to tip in my panties right
now,
but thank you for saving my life.
And then you drop us to the boat and
then we get to the boat and the guy's
like,
oh,
I didn't put enough gas in the boat.
Oops.
I'm like,
what?
So he ran out of gas at a gas.
So you were.
He would never be able to get you never.
Holy Shit.
It was so bad.
And then we managed to.
The coast guard came and they tried to
build a boat and he started telling the
the coast guard to like,
go screw himself because because I don't
want to pay for this.
You already Bush of assholes.
I'm like,
can you stop talking right now?
Oh my God.
And you literally insulted him so badly
to Colbert left.
Did they take you with them now?
That was the only boat with my friends
ever.
Drinking.
No understanding what was going on.
Like,
what are you so mad?
I'm like,
just just keep drinking.
So how'd you get back?
And then he managed to find full
reception.
You call the cousin of his wife is his
neighbor of this and that to come tow
him.
He arrived like about an hour and a half
later I got back to shore and the guy's
like,
oh,
so what time are you going tomorrow?
I'm like,
screw you.
I'm leaving.
I'm going tomorrow.
What a fucking delusional.
So bad.
And then we get to know you almost died.
And I left in the ocean and I didn't
have any gas and I told the coast guard
to go,
fuck.
Exactly.
I never see you ever again and we get to
the car and my friend is like,
oh,
I give him like $100 and tip.
Is that enough?
I'm like,
you did what?
You did what?
Now?
At
Lincoln and uh,
yeah.
So it was.
Yeah.
That was the scariest thing that's ever
happened to you in the water besides the
tiger shark?
Yeah,
definitely
for sure it was,
it.
Was there anything else like that?
That really freaked me out.
That should freak you out.
Five miles is a long way to swim,
especially if you don't swim distance
all the time.
Did you have any flotation device or
anything?
I have one buoy about that big and we
were too.
I was more scared because it was about
like four,
25.
So to sun was getting down really
quickly.
You wouldn't be able to see what the
shore is now?
Not by being with the lights?
Yes.
Could,
it's more.
I was more freaked about like when it's
dark and it's fuck fuck,
fuck,
fuck.
So I had moments and spearfishing.
That was a little bit freaky.
I also had a blackout last year.
So under water.
Yeah,
that's the biggest danger of spear
phishing is actually blacking out.
It's not sharks.
It's not getting bitten by an
underwater.
Yeah.
So basically what happens is that you
dive down and then when you come to the
surface,
if you stay too long,
um,
you,
you're on your way to the surface,
going to expand bag and then your
residual volume of area do you have left
and you and your lungs and becomes
really,
really small.
So then the presenters becomes too low
and then you pass out what becomes too
low,
the percentage,
percentage of oxygen in your lungs
become too small,
and then you just pass out.
So basically you brains shuts down to
make sure that a lack of oxygen is not
creating any permanent damages.
Oh,
what a Shitty CEO,
Steve.
It's actually kind of sport.
Not enough time,
but then that's what happens with people
is that when it come back up,
if you buddies not watching you,
and that's why I spear phishing is a
team sport.
If they're not watching you,
if you pass out on the water,
what if they pass out to a sink right
down.
You're both doing it at the same time.
Well,
normally.
Well the good system to dive is one
person dives at a bottom.
The person is watching the other one and
then this one up,
one down,
one up,
and then you.
You,
you watch each back.
Is that what happened with you?
Yeah,
it was actually very lucky.
I'm the guy that was diving with me.
I'm lost his brother a few years before
to blackout,
so he was looking at me very,
very closely and I was,
I was beyond grateful to see space at a
surface.
I knew anything was going to black out,
so how'd you know you're going to black
out?
Because it was.
I dove down and I was aiming at a fish.
It was pretty deep.
I was at 85 feet and I aimed for fish.
It was an impulse beard.
She wasn't a gun and I missed it and I
started using it in water and then I
miss it again.
I was like,
God dammit,
and then I realized I was like,
well,
why am actually pretty deep?
And I've been there for quite a while,
so I started panicking a little bit so
when you panic you let here even more,
which is completely stupid.
And then I started finning,
finning,
finning.
And then you have you started doing a
fitting?
Spinning.
I'm finishing a when we have new wear
fins
kicking around.
You taking.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
And then what happens first before you
black out is you have a loss of motor
control.
So I could start feeling,
I could feel like my body making like
we're movements and then I knew that was
out of oxygen and then I knew that I
would probably most probably going to
pass out and then I came back.
I came back and the nice thought of my
friend who was watching and I was like,
oh,
I really hope you really watching your
view really watching.
And he grabbed me and then he woke me up
and it was.
How far were you from the surface and
you blacked out?
I blacked out a surface at the surface.
Which is why it's called a shallow water
blackout because even if you're in
deeper water it most of the time it
happens at the surface.
So when you got to the surface,
what did he have to do to wake you up?
Or you have to take the mask off.
You have to keep the head of the water
and then you have to blow in the eyes
because he has a high concentration of
nerves.
You slapped a little bit,
not too hard.
Call the person's name and then you
normally wake up pretty,
pretty fast unless you inhale water.
What was it like?
You are a dream like if you get choked
out,
like one of the things that happens when
you get choked out as you wake up.
It's like you were dreaming.
I was at a disco.
I was riding my skateboard.
It's weird.
I've never been choked out to the point
of passing out
luckily for me.
But yeah,
I missed out on going a few,
a few minutes and I just wasn't sure
what was going on.
And then you just,
you just done for the day when it
happens,
but you have to be done.
Huh?
It's,
yeah,
for the,
the risk of getting another one the same
day.
It's actually very high.
Wow.
So once you shut off,
shut off again.
So you have to wait at least the
following day to get back into water the
next day.
I think I did,
it was the day after I really want to go
back in the water as soon as possible.
Just jumped back on the horse.
So at night I was a little bit stressed
out and my friend gave me some Kratom
and it was fun.
That's stuff I used to think that stuff
that Kratom was um,
I didn't think it was a drug.
I thought it was a mild stimulant.
I heard that people take it for pain,
but I thought that when they're taking
it for pain,
that they're not getting high,
they're just taking,
it alleviates pain like advil or
something like that.
And then I took,
I think I took eight of them,
eight or 10,
which is a lot because I know Chris bell
takes like 10 every day.
Yeah.
Powder mixed with like,
yeah,
this is just the powder in pill form.
And I was high as fuck.
And I was like,
oh,
okay.
Now I know why people are nervous about
this stuff.
I mean,
but the weird thing is I was high but my
body was very functional.
Like I was high but I wasn't
uncoordinated.
I wasn't knocking things over.
It wasn't that everything worked normal.
Like everything was,
was moving as I wanted it to move.
But I was like Whoa,
I fucking tripping.
It is an opiate.
It operates on your opiate receptors and
some sort of strange way,
which is one of the reasons why they're
making the argument that it should be
illegal,
but is if,
if any opioid is legal,
it should be that one because it helps
people tremendously with addiction
tremendously with pain.
It doesn't seem to be toxic to the point
where it can kill you or it's very,
very rare that it does.
It seems to operate in a completely
different way than any other opiate and
like I said,
even though I was definitely high,
like I was definitely under the
influence of something.
Nobody,
I don't think anybody knew.
I mean I could have conversations with
people,
but in the back of my head I was like,
oh,
hi.
I'm talking to people.
And it was all totally normal.
I wasn't driving,
but if I was driving I think I'd be
fine.
I'm fine.
I was fine.
Walk,
I think even worked out.
I think yeah,
it's just,
it's just operates in a very different
way.
It's um,
I've never,
I mean I've,
I've had my knee operation,
I had one of my knee operations.
They gave me a morphine button,
like when I was in the hospital,
like they said,
if you want morphine,
just press that button and it'll give
you some morphine.
I fucking hate that guy.
Once he,
once you get high off the morphine and
you're in the hospital was great.
Keep pressing the button and the pain of
the knees.
It was on.
Um,
also my knee was on this motion machine
right after the,
uh,
the surgery was done.
They put me on this machine that extends
and contracts your name,
brings it back and forth and that's not
comfortable,
but when you hit that morphine is fun.
But other than that I never really have
had opiates,
I don't think,
except
they gave me a pain pill prescription.
I don't remember what kind it was.
It was Vicodin or percocet or one of
those.
I took it once and I hated it.
It just made me feel really stupid.
Like I just remember thinking my brain's
just really dull and I still could feel
the pain.
I just didn't care.
It was weird,
you know.
So those morphine buttons are very
dangerous.
When I got my permission,
I keep us in the button too.
Is that,
that it was really fun.
I did.
It told me,
well,
it's time to go home.
And I stood up and I fell right on my
face.
I had a complete faceplant.
Really?
Yeah,
like an actual complete face plant.
Oh,
what were you in the hospital for?
I was a earn yum.
Hernia.
And they didn't ask you or how many
times you press that button,
Valentine?
They did.
They definitely did seem to have taking
into consideration my weight.
Oh yeah.
Right.
You're trying to.
Well why wouldn't they ask you how many
times you press the button before they
let you get up?
I,
I don't know.
But I remembered a woman being like the
nerves being like,
like you had,
you had a lot.
You show you one more,
you shoot that much.
If I was bringing in.
Well,
once you're under the influence of it,
imagine you don't really worry about it.
Nah,
you know,
until you pass out.
Well Listen Valentine.
I'm glad we did this.
It was really fun.
I'm glad we had this conversation.
I think,
like I said,
I think what you're trying to do with
your life is admirable.
Life is short.
I wish more people would chase their
dreams and live their lives in a way
that they want to rather than just jump
into the fucking rat race.
I'm,
I'm definitely,
definitely not regretting any second of
it.
So I'm happy I did that.
Thank you so much for having me here and
it's crazy how you came up.
I was asking a friend of mine from
podcast to listen.
Then he talked to me about yours and so
as I was sitting at a beach in the
Bahamas,
then my friend that went to law school
with me,
it was like,
oh,
you should listen to draw organ.
Podcast is awesome.
I look you up in instagram and I say,
you will follow me.
Was like,
Nice.
There we go.
My friend was like,
what?
Yo Shit.
Well,
we did it.
Thanks for doing this and I hope maybe
this opens up some doors for you and
some things happen.
Well,
if people start,
stop hiding behind their closed mind and
opinion.
I think so.
I think slowly but surely conversations
like this,
it'll open doors and change people's
perceptions and that's.
That's what I hope people got out of it.
That's good.
If I have one message today is talk
about it,
know where your food comes from and
don't be.
Don't be scared to see what's going on
and live the life to the way you want,
and that's what you're doing.
Oh yeah.
Get Out of your comfort zone because you
never going to discover the person you
are this thing in there.
Boom.